okay so a fist fight almost broke out in
the senate in in one of the hearings
today and Bernie Sanders ruining all my
fun we had two adult men agreeing to a
mutual combat situation and Bernie
Sanders starts yelling like you are a
United States Senator sit down and like
you know he's yelling at him and then uh
no kidding this really happened I
definitely want to talk about it and
then we had um probably the more
important story is Kevin McCarthy
physically attacking a rep who voted
against him uh uh this rep brette says
that he was elbowed a straight kidney
shot and Kevin McCarthy is trying to
backway like I was just walking through
the hall and I bumped into him that's
all that happened and these reporters
are like dude the hallway is massive how
do you accidentally bump into a guy in
the hallway like No One Believes you
plus a reporter from NPR are watched it
happen so we definitely got to talk
about this and uh you know I don't know
a bunch of other stories we got some
some weird and wild ones and wokeness uh
an account on X posted a picture of a
black Santa Claus in a wheelchair
ornament that Target is selling I did
not believe it was real and I pulled it
up on the Target website so I just got
to say man you know Target I don't know
they they they can't seem to learn their
lesson about just doing this weird stuff
and I guess it's fine like if anybody
wants to buy that ornament I got no beef
it's just Target I don't know who you're
marketing toward so we'll talk about
that before we get started my friends
head over to cast brew.com if you'd like
to purchase coffee and have the best cup
of coffee you've ever had check out our
rise with Roberto Jr Halloween limited
edition it's uh we're making fun of our
own dead mascot Roberto Jr the rooster
with his zombie chicken foot coming out
of the ground once these are gone they
will never exist again so if you want to
uh get them and you want to keep the bag
then I suggest you buy them now but
everyone's favorite of course is rise
with Roberto Jr the original before good
sir Roberto Jr passed away and
Appalachian night is my favorite but
stand your grounds is good we got a
whole bunch of different stuff we got K
Cups we got everything when you buy
Casper not only are you getting the best
cup of coffee you've ever had but we are
also building coffee shops and all of
the pressional equipment arrived last
week we're really excited so things are
moving the renovations are happening and
that's what you are supporting physical
loc locations where people can hang out
and uh hopefully in 10 years there's you
know hundreds of these all over the
country and we get uh we get something
wrong with there but also head over to
timcast.net infringed by Lauren Southern
really do recommend you check it out
it's about gun rights if you believe in
the right to defend yourself and you
believe in the Second Amendment then uh
become a member Watch the documentary
share it with your friends share with
people who may not be familiar with gun
culture and gun rights I recommend it
and also uh you'll be able to watch the
uncensored members only show coming up
tonight at 10 p.m. and as a member you
can even submit questions and call in
and talk to us and our guests so smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more is Lauren Chen hey
great to be back thank you for having me
yeah who are you what do you doing so I
am Lauren Chen I am a Blaze TV host as
well as TPA contributor and actually if
you guys are subscribed to the blaze
you'll know that we just put out a
really cool documentary about what
really happened in Maui regarding the
lahina fires so it was we were on
location in on Maui really beautiful
place but it was terrible what happened
we were there with the actual crew that
used to work with Tucker Carlson for his
Tucker Carlson original series uh so
they were just total pros and yeah it's
actually investigative on the ground
journalism which we don't really see the
mainstream media do that much anymore so
if you want to check it out uh
blazetv.com and you can use the code
Lauren plus to save money on your annual
subscription and I am also just a humble
soap Merchant as well uh if you guys are
in in the market for any bath or body
products and you don't want to support
you know the woke companies uh support
small business made in Nashville
Tennessee uh yeah you can check it out
at etsy.com shop clearly pure spelled c
l e a r l y p u r and uh yeah actually
Ian this one's for you oh my gosh
salivating eyeballs are are buts we got
beard bombs soaps uh yeah tons of gift
baskets and we have a Black Friday sale
going on right now you guys can save
money if you use the code tim1 for
orders over 75 Tim 20 for orders over
100 and a Tim 25 for 25% off orders over
12 so yeah appreciate everyone who's
already shopped and left reviews means
means a lot right on you see what you
see what the reason they do the code
like that is because then they know how
many people from this show are buying
the products right exactly exactly so
don't let me down guys come on you know
you're going embarrass me in front of
Lauren yeah you guys all have to get
your family's Christmas presents exct
Black Friday sales family business hard
to go wrong yeah don't you want to smell
like Lauren Chan I'm just kidding I
can't I can't say that she personally
smells like this I'm Han brim I'm a
writer for
timcast.net
and of course we have Ian who's checking
out all that Beetle song don't let me
down you know that one that John lenon
is saying don't let me down well what's
the website exactly
etsy.com shop clearly pure CLE e a r l y
p u r and I apologize that our redirect
is not currently working uh clearly pure
I you gave me some of this before and it
was so good this is here Ian so pepper I
do so cuz it goes right through your
skin so you want to treat it like eat
organic and use organic so natural oils
avocado oil that's what our soaps are
made from whenever whenever Alison and I
will go out somewhere and there's like
some hippie soaps for sale we'll be like
oh we'll get that for Ian and then
whenever we tell people like we always
buy Ian soap they give us this look as
if the implication is something's wrong
with Ian like no no it's just that he's
like he lik smells wonderful
because exactly yeah my mom makes
everything herself and she knew that
last time like you you were you were a
fan so she gave you like a ton of stuff
thank you so much to your mother whole
show is a soap ad now now it is coffee
what more do you need I'm going to Tweet
out the link to the store so people have
that so every so now that Hannah clar
and I have already introduced themselves
yes oh yeah we have this guy name searge
oh yes I also should say thank you to
giving me the same or a similar basket I
appreciate it as well it's always good
to see you here uh especially someone
that's like a fellow Southeast Asian
third culture kid you know so yeah for
sure we're holding down the fort with a
Celsius oh yeah definitely all all right
shall we jump to the news yep ladies and
gentlemen I don't know if this is the
most important story but it's certainly
one of the was fun and Bernie Sanders
has to go and spoil everything when I S
when when you search for the story about
the fist fight that nearly occurred in
the senate in a senate hearing most
headlines are like Bernie Sanders stops
fist fight and he did and I am upset
with Bernie okay okay I'm not really you
know that you shouldn't fight in the
Senate but here's the story Senator
Mullins challenges Teamsters president
to fight during Committee hearing
Senator Mark way Mullen a republican
challenged teamers president Sean
O'Brien to a fight during a senate
committee on health education labor and
pensions committee hearing on Tuesday I
I really would love to get Senator
Mullen on the show now because this was
it's just like absolutely epic and uh
let me so Shan M O'Brien has been making
fun of Mullins he tweeted greedy CEO who
pretends like he's self-made in reality
just a clown and fraud always has been
always will be quit the tough guy act in
the Senate hearings you know where to
find me any place anytime Cowboy #
Littleman syndrome and there's a a photo
of him standing on a box during a debate
or something like this and uh you know
what I I'm I'm just gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna play the video for you guys and uh
you can listen for yourselves like he
self-made sir I wish he was in the truck
with me when I was building my plumbing
company myself and my wife was running
the office because I sure remember
working pretty hard in long hours
pretends like he's self-made what a
clown fraud always has been always will
be quick the tough guy act in these
Senate hearings you know where to find
me any place anytime
Cowboy sir this is a time this is a
place you want to run your mouth we can
be to consenting adults we can finish it
here okay that's fine do it now I'd love
to do it right now well stand your butt
up then you stand your butt up oh
stop go for theing sit down sit down you
know you're a United States Senator sit
sit down please all right I resp hold it
hold
it if we can no I have the I'm sorry
this you'll have your time okay can I
respond oh no you
can't
hearing oh wow in our official
government record like okay but my
question is does this happen more or
less often now that there are cameras
televising this than in the past well
there was that Democrat who just
announced he's retiring and one of his
big critiques was that Congress is
performative that everyone's just
looking have their viral moment but what
I like about this and I did confirm this
just now uh is that Mullins is in fact a
former undefeated MMA champion no wait
what official bio on the Senate Mark
Wayne Mullins is a former undefeated
mixed martial arts MMA fighter with a
professional record of 5 and0
oh he was inducted into the Oklahoma
Wrestling Hall of Fame in 2016 so I'm
telling you this would have been amazing
wow man wow I'd like I would love to get
him on maybe a culture War episode you
got to get him and the teamster though
no they'll fight exactly it's it's not
really a culture War episode I'm just
saying like some sort of Logan Paul
boxing match yeah that's who needs to
reach out to them Paul what are you
doing here team I I just I I just got I
gotta say let's be real okay here's Mr
O'Brien yo this this dude would get
rocked by m yeah get push he push him
and then he'd get choked no this this
guy probably wouldn't last five seconds
he he probably put him in a choke really
fast or like an arm bar or something
who's older I I'm assuming he's older it
looks like him but I'm not sure he might
have an ill fitting
gu this guy who this so into it who's
this guy what is this I think he's
probably anban who is like let's go this
is what a came here for I just you know
that Meme where it's like the two women
are like and they cover their mouths and
the guy just smiles yeah like I imagine
a lot of the guys in there watching this
Heaven started laughing like let's go
the Bernie Bernie like really came off
as a badass except if he was bigger and
stronger than the other dudes I would
have been like President he is like the
high school teacher coming out into the
hallway being like everybody go go to
your rooms this isn't okay killing the
fun and I think I mean Mark Wayne
Mullins is interesting to me because
he's one of the only Tradesman who own
who has a seat in the Senate right and
actually theoretically Bernie Sanders
also lists himself as a former Carpenter
and so we have Tradesman V Tradesman V
Teamster which I find interesting look
at do you think that was a planned
moment or it's just a moment of passion
calling I think he went in knowing he
would threaten to fight him I just don't
he was expecting a response of like yes
I will fight you now so here's a tweet
from citizen Free Press update Mullen
posts a picture with his guns and
challenges Teamster boss Shawn O'Brien
to a fight wonderful duel cuz he's got
he says let's do it any place anytime
and then he tagged comfortably smug in
it comfortly swug said this is an
invitation for Senator Mullen to come on
ruthless podcast oh okay he's not he
threatening to duel right okay citizen
pre is wrong he's responding to the
podcast saying he's going to go on to
podcast oh hey Senator Mullins we'd love
to have you on we we definitely got to
talk about this yeah be fantastic Let's
Make A Make Some Noise about the
challenge do you think that watching
dude's fight makes culture become more
combative or is it like an outlet or do
you think that we should see people
fight because then we know that there
are correct times to channel aggression
instead of just letting people be
weirdly passive aggressive forever until
they default into extreme violence right
because we're seeing less violence from
our at least elected officials than ever
but at the same time I feel like we're
more in terms of rhetoric and division
like we've gone further to the extreme
so maybe it's we're actually lacking the
consequences that comes from this
rhetoric that would naturally kind of
pull people back maybe we do need to see
that oh yeah words have consequences you
can't just mouth off and expect nothing
to happen like people eventually will
call you out and some people like Mullen
they might be willing to go to blows
yeah I always heard the big difference
between men and women was that women are
sort of pass aggressive they hold
grudges forever but also they are not PR
to violence whereas men if they have a
conflict ultimately it always could come
to like hitting each other but then at
that point you've decided who's sort of
in charge so you can almost move past it
often yelling with the two guys guy
friends will like yell at each other I
don't do it as much anymore but like
growing up it'd be like you'd scream it
out and then you'd be done and then it'd
be totally back to normal the next day
yeah yeah very different from women yeah
women would hold on to that for the rest
of their lives exactly each other but
they'd hate each other yeah he's the
only current he's the only currently
serving Senator without at least a
bachelor's degree M wow he's super cool
he also is like an active I think he uh
I don't know what the term is but he
like ranches he raises cows and stuff
like he an interesting he's a real
cowboy MMA fighter yeah I was working on
this piece for a long time where I was
like stalking all the professional
backgrounds of everyone in the Senate
and um he's really unique right there
are Senators that literally own uh MLB
teams and there's this guy who has a big
family and is actually a Tradesman who
built his company and then made to US
Senate like why don't we have more
people like that he's super rich let's
see it says between November 06 and
april7 Mullen fought in three MMA fights
winning all three his total fight time
was less than 10 minutes and he fought a
total of less than three full rounds
that's the way to win
wow mess that dude up yeah also he
should now fight every other American
Senator a not the women but like that
would be fascinating right well why not
you know what's gender soci yeah exactly
instead of this uh voting for our uh
speaker of the house we just have them
fight like that's how we should decide
political leadership yeah what is it
patriarchal Bloodlines in in ritual
combat uh Mark Wayne Mullen I want to I
want to make sure everybody on sense he
did not start the fight that dude
threatened him on Twitter and then and
then imagine I mean dude you're you're
you're like I'm here to do my job and
this guy's posting that he wants to
fight me that he's going to fight me and
then he's going to show up to where I'm
working and have to testify before me
I'm going to call him out for it I
respect it yeah and uh I as much as I
think uh all of the men listening are
like oh Bernie what are you doing okay
Bernie we we the the responsible
portions of the male brain are saying I
know it was the you should stop the
fight nobody wants to get it but you
know the the the the more primate part
of the brain is screaming birdie no yeah
it was um it was I mean it would have
set a precedent of that fighting in
there is okay if they'd fought but I
think if they both if they both agreed
to it then why wouldn't we a gentleman's
duel well that's the thing mutual combat
is legal in a lot of places I don't know
if it's legal in DC let me check
actually I think in Oregon mutual combat
there's no crime if two people agree to
fight dude that guy that ball dude was
going to get rocked he had no idea he
was talking crap people that haven't
gotten hit or been in a fight before
they're always think they're going to
win in a situation like that they think
a little bit bigger than them it's not
always how it works man well he knew
someone would intervene I just you know
could you imagine this guy waking up in
the morning and be like Bernie Sanders
is going to intervene on my behalf to
fight my only only organ is Washington
State and Texas have mutual combat laws
uh both both parties must agree to the
fight it must be in public and there can
be no serious bodily injury to the
partic uh to the partic uh to the
participants but how do they distinguish
between that and something like the UFC
because you could do UFC in Las Vegas I
mean isn't that technically a mutually
agreed upon fight I think they're called
sanctioned fights like could be
sanctioned something about that like
they get permits for these fights to
happen and everybody knows that like you
know the best MMA fights are after the
fight over the dudes T touch gloves give
a hug and then go like they know that're
they don't hate each other they're
trying to be the best fighter that I
love watching that I can't stand the
snoody MMA fighters who are like smack
talking and I'm like I get it they're
trying to like get attention and build
Rings or whatever but I like the fights
when a dude loses and the other guy like
gives him a fist Bunch they shake hands
or whatever well my husband he's really
into UFC he watches it like B basically
any Saturday that there's a fight but he
was saying that the re there's an
incentive for them to trash talk and try
to make it as toxic as possible because
then it draws View and then like their
bag's bigger and there's just more
attention on them exactly exactly you
want people to you you want people to
hope you lose yeah then more money comes
in everybody wants to watch because
they're looking for the villain and it's
like yeah you know whatever that
happened with that Logan Paul fight
recently that some guy was like talking
about his his ex-girlfriend or his wife
I don't even want to propagate the
nonsense but Logan went in there and
decimated the dude yeah and then it
didn't get any didn't get as much
attention as I would have I mean they
weren't like top billing or anything no
now my friends while uh many of you may
may be sad to hear that the fight didn't
actually happen don't worry a different
fight did we got this from the New York
Post rep Tim brette accuses bully Kevin
McCarthy of attacking him with quote
clean shot to the kidneys in Capitol
hallway Yep this one's hilarious and uh
as much as they're saying it's a claim
and it's alleged an NPR reporter was
standing there recording and tweeted out
she saw this happen that McCarthy came
up from behind him and shoved him and
she thought it was a joke and then a
Chase ensued where started yelling at
McCarthy and what brette said is that he
got he elbowed him straight in the
kidneys so this brette voted against
Kevin McCarthy McCarthy is it's it's a
mental breakdown dude Matt Gates pointed
out at our Miami event this is so
amazing So Glorious that McCarthy gets a
billion dollars or whatever in these in
these in this month you know and money
for the RNC and for his campaign and all
this stuff so he has control but you
know he owes people now he's got to
deliver as Speaker of the House now that
he's removed he cannot deliver on those
promises and those IUS are now basically
toilet paper I can't imagine what it
must be like to sell your soul out to is
effectively the mafia and then only what
like a month later be like I am no
longer in the position to pay you back I
don't think the dudes who gave you that
money will take that for an answer and
so Kevin McCarthy is probably freaking
out and sweating bullets and uh not too
happy with the people who voted against
him no but it's also it it's just so
corrupt I mean it's this is exactly why
we should have term limits because
you're exactly right that is how DC
works but it it shouldn't be and that's
it it's just so so toxic I don't like
the idea of well lately I thought about
maybe evolving our Our House of
Representatives into like the entire
population so that we all have the
opportunity to pass to set up bills them
no we still have the Senate so and the
the republics would still they'd still
be there and if the power goes out we
would send them all to the capital so
they'd still have their job they would
just be part of the population and like
deciding bills and sending them to the
Senate cuz there it's too easy to bribe
those 450 people
MH I feel like that would be really hard
to get things done I'm not Asos to the
efficiency of DC now right but at least
some stuff does happen but maybe we just
but maybe that's exactly why we should
do that because it would be really hard
to get stuff done maybe maybe we want it
depends on what you want like if you
want to impeach mayorcas and we're not
doing that anyways perhaps that system's
the same right but if you want any
funding for the Border or anything that
you do want push through Congress then
having a convoluted system might be I
don't okay well we've got a video from
Kevin McCarthy who's responded uh and
citizen Free Press says Kevin McCarthy
sounds like a man who has caught
red-handed hitting Tim brette I guess
our Shoulders hit I did not run and hit
the guy I did not kidney punch him
reporter immediately grills McCarthy
over his claims here we go a reporter
was interviewing Bard or something I
guess our Shoulders hit because bir runs
up to me after I didn't know what he was
talking about so before was asking me I
did not run and hit the guy I did not
kidney punch him I did not shoot
anything like you didn't shove him no I
we walking through you you were at hc5
right you guys line up along the way
there it was Bruce Wester and I walking
out he must have been interviewing
somebody I didn't know it was him or
something I guess our elbow hit as I
walked by I didn't punch
anybody yeah well he I guess it happened
because when I was walking back further
I say somebody was interviewing me or
talking to me and he comes running up
like why why why did you hit me or
something like that I said I don't know
what you're talking about I didn't even
know something transpired but reporters
witness that said it looked like you
there was plenty of room for you to walk
and then you intentionally hit him where
is okay not a place show me a reporter
who saw
that ask Bruce Wester no I did not go up
if
I he's trying to like over justif like a
to much
talking now he said the bigger the story
the bigger the LIE he would no I didn't
walk twice while he was in Congress in
the chamber
when have I pushed him kininger said he
was in the back railing once and you
elbowed him and pushed him kininger k no
I don't I don't know you rewind that he
thought that they said Matt Gates he's
got Gates on the bra let's let's play it
you pushed him twice while he he said he
he said he was in pain that you hit him
so hard in on now that's what he said
okay that's far
from Congressman Congressman kinzinger
wrote that you pushed him twice while he
was in Congress in the chamber when have
I pushed him kininger said he was in the
back railing once and you elbowed him
and pushed him
GES the girl behind him said Gates okay
Congressman Gates though is filing or uh
committ submitting a complaint to the
Ethics Committee over this this issue do
you have any Congressman Gates no I I
think ethics is a good place for gates
to be can I ask B said that you're the
kind of guy this his word a r throw a
and then go hide under his mom's skirt
that was what's your response is
Congress is there bad blood between you
in berett yes none at all after he voted
to U what would you just say about the
issue of decorum in Congress I mean
there was a house oversight hearing
where a member was called a Smurf you
have over in the Senate
today you have Senator Mullen who was
like about to fight
[Laughter]
oh this is great why do you think things
are so tense sorry why do you think I I
think members have been W should have
been like oh you elow me in the kidney
he's got Gates on the brain yeah and
brette was at a a a a DC young
Republicans event theight before and
called Kevin McCarthy bitter I mean they
they know what's happening this is all
all of their staffers probably talked
about all day when she asked him if he
had bad blood with that dude he looked
away and looked back at her and said no
like that's a lying when you look up to
the left that mean that's an indication
that you're lying but I guess to play
Devil's Advocate apparently there were
reporters around when this happened why
would he do it in front of a reporter
because he has no selfcontrol yeah he's
he's having a mental breakdown dude he
was before he was even voted in a
speaker he was moving into the speaker's
office and Matt Gates called him out for
it this dude was having a temper tantrum
the whole time I have to imagine that
when Kevin McCarthy was facing that
showdown in the first vote to put to put
him in a speaker he was probably scared
as hell that he was not going to get it
and when he he's like I I'm just going
to move my stuff and I'm going to get it
it's going to happen I'll do what I have
to do to get it and he finally got it I
bet the dude cried I bet he went home
when he was crying like finally speak
and then sure enough like what is it
like a month or so later like two months
later he's gone he's he's got to act as
cool and collect it as he can but
clearly the dude is Unwound and he's
walking down the hallway and this dude
voted to OU him it was eight Republicans
that did it and he albow him in the back
a reporter watched it happen dude is
losing his mind yeah I can't imagine the
stress that this kind of public you know
life brings to anyone but it does seem a
little weird that you would be like
there's that guy for the first time I'll
hit him on the other hand like maybe
that is a sign that you know Congress is
as unstable as it looks from the outside
I mean at least Mark Wayne Mullins you
know formally challenged him to
basically a duel but with your hands
whereas this seems like a like cheap
shot you know Sucker Punch type of thing
yeah Mullen confronted the guy who who
who called him out and said he wanted to
fight stands up and I love when he goes
for his his wedding ring he's like I'm
he left it on he left it on right cuz
Bernie was like Sit Down You're son of
your wife so funny this is uh this
McCarthy guys had me on edge the entire
time and I kind of kept my mouth shut in
the first few months that he was speaker
because I wanted the best for the house
but he sounded like Trudeau the whole
time his voice and he talks like this
and he has the kind of voice and now his
voice is going up and down when he's
trying it's just so pandering and oh
like where's the authority in this voice
it's he's such like a I don't know I
don't want to do um m is just they go
back to the question of decorum right
and do we need deorum this is a some a
criticism that gets leved at Trump all
the time that he doesn't have decorum
that he doesn't act presidential but
maybe people don't want that I mean I
think of the British Parliament and they
I don't know that anyone challenges
anyone to a fight on the floor of
parliament but they yell they're much
similar in Australia too exactly I think
you need about as much decorum as Bernie
Sanders like no I didn't say that like
that kind of decorum like willing to
kind of like take off his tie or get his
tie undone if he's getting hot but like
not throw cups at people and stuff like
that like he he has a limit to the there
was some Senator I can't remember who it
was who threw a snowball at someone
during a debate on global I'll find the
name was that recently it was a long
time ago cuz I think I I was writing
about it I think it might have been
tesser from alasa I could be wrong on
this I'll check in a second but they
were having a debate on global warming
and so he went out scooped up SN and
then like threw it across the chamber at
him like there have been weird funny
moments and I guess you know we weren't
allowed to throw snowballs at my school
because they could have pebbles in them
and you could hurt someone yeah same
same but I mean there's a difference
between decorum and vital and you could
say like okay we're going downhill in
terms of decorum because we should all
be polite and things like that but in
terms of just I mean we have been
accusing each other Congressmen have
have been accusing each other of things
like racism and Corruption for a long
time like that's not new so I mean
either way these people are they're
going they're backstabbing each other
they're trying to ruin each other's
careers is it a big deal that they might
I mean now it might just be coming to
the surface a little bit more I don't
think so I mean I think the the lack of
professionalism lack of unity was
already there it's just a little bit
more apparent now when the snowball was
uh Jim inhoff of Oklahoma which is also
where Mark Wayne Mullin is from so maybe
those Oklahoma
boys on the great PL Trump when he said
Rosie O'Donnell is a fat he didn't say
that well how did he say it she said uh
Megan Kelly asked about how you've
insulted women referring to some as you
know fat pigs or whatever and he says
only Rosie odonnell okay and then that
means in the past he has called her a
fat or he's acknowledging that he did
call her a fat pig in the P I don't
think he's he I don't think he was
implying that he literally said the
words fat pig but that he was implying
that he's insulted only Rosie O'Donnell
or something like that that I think is
unless he meant literally the only
person he's called a fat pig was her
when it goes too far as when you're in
public office and you're using your time
publicly to insult people like with mean
like you dumb idiot that thing because
then that just wastes time wastes
taxpayer money I don't want that in my
office I agree but personally I don't
think calling someone like a fat cow is
any worse than slandering someone as
like a white supremacist or a racist or
whatever you know you know what I mean
like one might be construed as like more
Street and fighting words but personally
I would rather be called a fat cow than
you know like an anti-semite that could
actually ruin your career in this day
and age and Congressmen have been
calling people that for a long time and
I got to tell you uh Ian more the more
time they spend insulting each other is
less time they spend on giving our money
away for BS government projects in war
so I would much prefer it you know IAL
we talked about this yesterday with war
that I would take the entire War budget
and just give it to some random guy
because some random American dude can
spend it infinitely better than we waste
on all these wars like 20 years in
Afghanistan but uh I would rather every
single member of Congress engaged in
narcissistic mudslinging on the on the
floor if it meant they weren't all in
lock step with funding war and foreign
intervention that kind of backs up my my
suggestion that we disperse the House of
Representatives if they're that useless
and you'd rather just see them insulting
each other they really have no place in
this country we we we the people can
pass laws and bills into the Senate we
don't need these 450 stop Gap bribery uh
vulnerabilities anymore I dis agree I
think they can join us in our citizen I
think the answer is not to abolish
Congress it's to reform or amend like
all the people need to get voted out we
need better rules clearly the system is
busted Mike grel had the fourth branch
of government he wanted to create called
the national initiative he was a senator
from um um from um Alaska and then it
would create a fourth branch government
that's the people the people would
represent local people to go and act as
another form of like a representative of
the people themselves instead of that
feels like it just makes the government
bigger yeah and they more bribery
vulnerabilities it's quite literally
more members of Congress either we do it
ourselves and there's 330 million of us
and you can't bribe us all no we need to
repeal the 17th Amendment and we need
people to focus on their local politics
more and stop acting like Kevin mcth can
do anything for you the dude does not
represent any of us in any way okay he
represents his district to the federal
government he does not represent you as
a person people think that our federal
elected representatives are going to do
anything for us at home and that's what
I I've long complained about this you
see these Congressional ads where
they're like I'm going to clean up this
town no you're not you're going to
Congress you're going to DC you're going
to go vote on war and other garbage if
you want to clean up your town if you
want to fix your crime you got to vote
for local reps and so a lot of and and
your Governors and your state senators
and things like like that you want to
know why California's all messed up it's
because they they vote for these people
locally it's not anything the federal
government's doing yeah they can't also
they can't read these 3,000 page bills
it's but if we crowdsource it and we let
the entire US population have at it you
better believe there's going to be at
least 700 people that are going going to
go read those 3,000 Pages they do they
they do this yeah but then these are the
people that we need like pushing the
bills this was once called well no the
issue is that members of Congress should
have to read the bills before they vote
on them but they don't do it we should
make it what was your idea you you make
it a felony to vote on a bill that you
have not read yeah you have to swear
under oath that you've read the bill if
you're going to vote on it I would
support that I don't know what the
argument against that would be they're
corrupt and they want to sell out their
positions to lobbyists right I mean but
the the the position that they could
defend publicly for having that be like
the spin I'm trying to think about like
I mean I think what they would say and I
don't believe this but the Counterpoint
would probably be you know it would be
impossible us to to produce a effective
legislation that wasn't lengthy and so
actually you're making impossible for us
to get like you know they'd make like
you're slowing us down argument but
maybe that that's the point yeah and
that's why we want to get rid of omnus
Omnibus bills like what mat is doing
yeah like with spending bills you used
to actually have to have different ones
and that was a lot more efficient
because you could actually know where
the money was going but they want the
big bills so they can all slip their
pork in there and lobbyist can be like
haha like a little little nut for me
here little little presence and then uh
I I don't know if you guys follow Rand
Paul's like
every year he he exposes how much money
is spent on useless things like giving
Birds cocaine and studying that or
whatever it is but no it's it's crazy
and it's literally I would say criminal
how much how much they steal from
taxpayers on useless things he calls
that the Festivus his Festivus recount
or something like that yeah all right
ladies and gentlemen uh I want to play
this video for you of Nikki Haley and
explain to you why it is that you must
vote for Donald Trump and why it is this
woman should never be any allowed
anywhere near the seats of power reclaim
the net says Nikki Haley says if she's
made president president every social
media user will be verified by their
name for national security purposes and
we will uh we'll play that video for you
when I get into office the first thing
we have to do social media accounts
social media companies they have to show
America their algorithms let us see why
they're pushing what they're pushing
okay that I like but carry on the second
thing is every person on social media
should be verified by their name that's
first of all it's a national security
threat when you do that all sudden
people have to stand by what they say
and it gets rid of the Russian Bots the
Iranian Bots and the Chinese Bots and
then you're going to get some civility
when people know their name is next to
what they say accountability and they
know their pastor and their family memb
is going to see it it's going to help
our kids and it's going to help our
country okay the funny thing about that
is uh she's completely wrong uh this
country is built on Anonymous pamphlet
and writing and uh Benjamin Franklin and
Thomas Jefferson and many others so uh
what she's doing is she's taking things
that Elon Musk has pointed out which are
good ideas the option to be verified and
the choice to interact with those who
are and turning it into the government
will force you to do it and then she
immediately goes first of all she's like
everyone needs to have their name
attached their social security or to
their social networking first of all
it's a national security threat like
yeah that would be a national security
threat if you forced everyone to put
their name on their social no no no but
but but you get the point is she
inverted it she didn't mean it to sound
like that the reason she's called a
national security threat that Anonymous
accounts is because that is they're hard
you can't stop us we don't need a vote
justification we are going to send a
national security letter to to X and
force them to do it to Facebook etc etc
they're going to make you do it the
purpose of Minds one of the main tenants
of mindes is that Anonymous social
networking is is a human right in my
opinion I don't know if Bill's actually
come out and literally said that social
media company I founded in 2011 with
Bill opman it's you have to be able to I
didn't think about it so deeply before
but it's exactly like you said man um
silence do good was Benjamin Franklin's
first pen name he couldn't get published
in his brother's paper when he was like
14 so he made some fake middleaged lady
and then he started getting published
and of course uh Poor Richard's Almanac
he was a guy named poor Richard and he
would seed like revolutionary content
into the populace because he always his
whole life he probably wanted to revolt
against the king but he wasn't able if
he said out loud they would have cut his
head off so he had to use a pen name and
if the same thing in modern day if it
becomes tyrannical especially when there
are people who feel like their anonymity
allows them to operate in society
because their views are not permitted I
mean to to confront you'd have to start
really unpacking what hate speech is in
America if you really wanted to take
away uh Anonymous speech online and
where where the boundaries of free
speech are and and that's what I think
you know I I'm not totally against her a
justification of like if you had to put
your name by everything you said maybe
you would operate differently maybe
that's good but there are people who
write you know under pen names because
they fear that they'll be targeted by a
progressive attorney general who might
go after their job or whatever else
because they believe something that's
not popular it starts to be this thing
where like I just wonder what box we're
opening and I'm not against the idea of
accountability online but uh at what
cost and what are we protecting it's
kind of ironic because Nikki Haley rails
against China just one of the many
countries she probably wants to go to
war with but at the same time I mean
this this is the exact same type of
police state that China is rightfully
criticized for so this is something that
she wants to introduce I mean it's like
she is on the wrong side of basically
every single issue which is almost
impressive she's like impressive batting
average for just like the George Bush
Republicans who basically killed the
party for an entire generation we should
just make it so that in order to pass a
bill the person who is proposing it has
to uh uh enter Tri legislation by combat
so to literally Force mull is all
getting all the stuff through you've got
you've got to carry the the the the the
bill passed through the GOL
Gladiators they all the congressman they
all have paddles and they
unironically enter in a new golden age
for America have you guys seen all those
studies where they they look at how high
testosterone and like gym attendance
correlates with right-wing views we
studied this yeah it's amazing within 24
hours you'll feel the right wi seeping
into you you start to work out Ian Ian
lifted the barbell one time and then
dropped it and then started praying I
just I become happy with myself when I'm
physically healthy and that's part of
like I maybe I want to conserve my life
and my surroundings because I appreciate
them more when I'm physically yeah mhm
that's true I think it does give you uh
it gives you a sense of value and
purpose which changes your how you
approach the world which is is very
interesting I guess what also that would
also get rid of all the octogenarians
that we have in Congress as well true
they couldn't keep up they' have the age
categories it's like 72 to 78 they all
fight
Mullin I fight Mullins that be so funny
uh the other thing that stood out to me
is that she said this is the first thing
I do in office and I guess my question
to you guys would be what would you want
whoever gets elected to do the first
what should be the first thing they do
when they get to office firing people
that's a great question something
secretive that is big and changes a lot
of stuff um but what she said about
making all these social networks free
their code I don't agree with anymore I
think we start with Tik Tok because it's
a foreign company and proof of concept
that they want to operate on us Shore
they have to free their software code
their algorithms and then if that turns
out that it's really great for society
then we can use that as a cast as belly
to cause meta to open up their code yeah
let me tell you so we have we have
social media people who work here at
timcast and we have the the semi
Unwritten rules of various social media
platforms when posting and Tik Tok is
the most insanely restrictive absolutely
insane face so YouTube surprisingly the
least well I I should pause Rumble is
the least ax and Rumble are like you
know basically anything goes just you're
you're good to go and we we love that
YouTube is actually one of the least
restrictive though they are fairly
restrictive yeah and it's it's crazy cuz
I I mean I got the Blaze's YouTube
channel suspended for an entire week
because I'm I'm not going to say what I
said about uh the Elliot page I'll
actually use the the name so I don't
want to get your your page suspended
either but um yeah that happened on
YouTube but it was for something that I
mean I feel like YouTube's
more selective about than something like
Facebook which yeah fa uh YouTube
actually does in some circumstances look
at context Facebook absolutely does not
and I'm not I'm not trying to defend
YouTube I think YouTube censorship is a
problem but Facebook is insanely bad and
Tik Tok is substantially worse it feels
like Facebook relies a lot more on AI
than than than alphabet and there's like
no legitimate appeals process it takes
forever whereas with YouTube we actually
have like reps we can contact at a
certain level on YouTube there's people
who will work with you Facebook doesn't
care yeah they don't they don't want you
to appeal because they've made a
decision and it's it's crazy like my
channel uh my page on on uh uh Facebook
got demonetized once for for lies uh an
organization claimed that one of my
videos was fake news and so it triggered
a hard
demonetization and my my my video that I
put up was 100% factually correct I
reached out to the organization and I
said my video is correct and they said
no it's not here's your headline and I
said the headline is a question and the
first sentence of the video is rejecting
the claims made by people who are
asserting this and they were like oh we
didn't actually watch it so a third
party flagged me to Facebook and got my
money turned off that's insane that's
what Facebook does it's not even about
their internal teams it's about them
letting leftist Progressive activists
and government agents and I got to
wonder with this election Integrity
partnership partnership stuff going on
I'm I'm wondering if you know maybe we
should reach out to members of Congress
who are working on this and the people
we know who are working on it and ask
them about what Facebook is doing with
the pointer Institute and the and the or
and and the power they give to third
parties to remove move content they
don't like but see that's why that's why
the left always wins and they're going
to keep winning I work with a ton of
right-wing conservative nonprofits I
mean people people like tpusa we would
never think hang on there's this huge
company that has control of information
I should petition them so that I'm in
charge of what people are allowed to
post like that would never enter into
like 99% of conservatives Minds the left
not only think this but they actually
put it into action and they insert
themselves into roles of power very
effectively unless unless the subject is
Israel yes unless it's like everybody's
just like there's then it's like the me
yeah right then it's just I don't know
what's going on that's the fascist bent
in people when they're like we got to
use the private companies to control
society and they'll use it through
legislation or through funding through
legislation yeah I don't like when that
happens I kind of want to answer your
your question about what I would do if I
became president Ro I don't have an
answer do you guys what would you do
well I I I like this tweet that V put
out the other day day I don't know if he
said it would be day one but I think it
should be day one immediately fire half
of uh like the the DC bureaucrats or the
civil servants just you know transfer
them I'm good with firing them I think
like if automatically there's half of
them I mean obviously we could talk
about the economic comp uh I guess
implications of that many people being
out of a out of a job but if it's like
if the federal government is so huge
where we actually need to talk about The
Economic Consequences of that many civil
servants losing their jobs then that's a
problem in and ofself he was saying
layoffs because that bypasses the
restrictions you can lay them off for
budgetary reasons and yes absolutely and
uh I would I would I would hope that
VI to the extent it is legally humanly
and economically possible maximizes
those layoffs there's no there's no you
know what it is so we were talking last
night about schools and I was saying
like abolish the doe and get rid of this
broken system we had Aaron mat on and he
was arguing that I'm an exception to the
rule I'm successful not everyone can do
that and my argument is if you don't
think or if you think that there is no
way to replicate in you know my success
in other people then what's the point of
school if School can't create a path
towards success for people to be then
what's the point of doing it and uh my
you know his his his his attitude was
basically there's a lot of good teachers
who are in these schools and this is my
point the government funds a project
hires a bunch of people and then says
okay this doesn't work but we can't stop
it now because we're addicted to it we
are economically addicted to this
industry if we stop funding schools
we're going to have hundreds of thousand
of people out of work we can't have it
the economy would collapse also because
we didn't allow for any competition I
mean there are private schools there are
home schools things like that but
obviously predominantly most people's
money are tied up in their taxes which
then go to their public school so they
rely on them I mean education in America
is ultimately a failing business so it
should close but it's falsely kept alive
and what Ron Paul said and it was funny
because when we had Ron on the show I
mentioned this to him and he was like
did I say that he said of the uh war in
a I think it was Afghanistan they're
saying we can't just withdraw because
because it will cause a bunch of
problems but as a doctor I know if you
prescribe the wrong medication and it is
causing problems you stop the medication
there's there's no excuse we're saying
we have to just keep doing it we are
addicted to these government programs
and the fear is oh but if we terminate
we're going to lose all these jobs don't
know don't care that was and especially
with education we can see the outcomes
right test scores are going down I mean
some of the places that have the highest
per student funding have the worst
results and I I'm someone who's very
pro- homeschooling and the response is
always like oh your kids aren't going to
be able to read you're not qualified
it's like I mean we see what the actual
results are from kids who are in public
schools public schools that are failing
them it's really hard for it to be worse
actual Justice Warrior Sean he did a
video where I think places in Baltimore
like there's a a lot of schools where
literally 0% like well or Oregon just
did away with their graduation
requirements and they're saying there
are learning losses because of coid but
also that means your system is pretty
weak that exactly three years could I
mean students really suffered during Co
for a lot of reasons but it also means
that like there was absolutely no
effective Effectiveness in online
schooling or anything else the teachers
that were tasked with having to educate
kids remotely couldn't do it this means
that our system is not adaptable this is
not this is not proof that you guys are
successful uh and I think to Tim's uh
medicine uh metaphor you know Ron Paul's
Ron Paul uh you know if they're saying
this is the thing you take to fix it you
go to public school the thing is doctors
will then say oh you're having side
effects from the medication I gave you
instead of stopping it they'll say take
five others take this other one take
this other one which is why you know we
get Universal preschool and we get all
these other programs that the government
is saying we're not effective but we're
going to continue to fund ourselves
until we figure out a way to keep this
failing system up and that's that's a
disservice to students and their parents
if you gave them I mean this is why I
love school choice if you gave them the
opportunity to spend their monies in a
way that better suited their children's
needs because there's no way bureaucrats
in Washington know children better than
their own parents they would probably be
more effective well that's the problem
though the the the Department of
Education and the public school system
it exists to benefit teachers to benefit
administrators it's not actually to the
benefit of the students and much
definitely not the benefit of the
parents I think one of the things you
said um Hannah clir exactly that that is
pretty profound is that the problem that
this this school the education system
the Department of Education is that
there's no they have a monopoly there's
no real viable op option if it does shut
down like there's not another system
where people can just go get jobs there
and and bring their kids over there and
there should be because the Monopoly
government monopolies are just as
dangerous as private sector monopolies
this is this is what I saw in Venezuela
when you went to go buy a cell phone
there were like six to eight stations I
I go to T-Mobile in the United States I
walk in there's a guy and he's like how
can I help you I I want a phone he's
like okay he gets his his tablet out and
he's like which phone do you want he
starts typing it all in here's your
number and okay it's going to cost this
I swipe the card it's kind of annoying
and then you're done in Venezuela you
had they had to create fake jobs for the
sake of propping up their fake economy
which didn't work obviously so they're
mandated to have a person who gets the
phone a person who asks you what kind of
phone you want a person who deals with
your phone plan a person who takes the
money a person who writes down the bill
like you walk in you say you say how can
I help you I would like to buy a new
phone okay let me fill out this form for
you here you go and go wait in that line
then you go wait in another line there's
another person there and which phone
would you like to buy okay fill out this
form and then go wait over here then a
guy takes the form from you then he says
okay now go wait over there then so it's
it's it's insane that's what we're doing
right now in this country and and I
think you made a good point I think you
you brought this up that the government
created a monopoly on schools by mass
funding it this is what happens when the
government guarantees the income there's
it's it's almost impossible to compete
but but then you'll see things like
FedEx ups and the Postal Service clearly
people don't like using the postal
service for whatever reason right and
you get you get private schools you get
home schools you get co-ops people do
have Innovation especially when they see
that the system is broken but it makes
me wonder you know you'll have student
you teachers who are promised if you if
you work in a public school for X number
of years will pay off your student loan
debt which we have also given you
because we're the government and we're
trying to help you uh and I would wonder
if it would be more interesting to see
those people go off and start are you
know monor schools in more places or
explore you know different opportunities
with the degree that they have I think
good teachers are really valuable it's
not to shame all of them but the
government just wants you to stay in its
broken system and it's willing to take
you down with it if you're a teacher and
I think you're right a good teacher a
competent teacher is going to flourish
even without the public school and the
teacher un safety net and we see that
with Charter Schools and private schools
and there are even I guess industrious
teachers who are creating their own
homeschool curriculums that could be
applied to different homeschool pods
like there there there's there's a des
need for teachers who are competent but
I don't think we do those teachers any
any service by subsidizing the
incompetent on and the government
doesn't reward teachers entrepreneurship
it just beats them back into submission
as much as they can until they you know
eventually establish something which is
not good I want to jump to uh this story
it's a tweet from the account end
wokeness end wokeness tweets Target
outdid itself this year for Christmas
and uh the first image I've seen before
it is what I would describe as gay
nutcrackers okay I'm not that that is
not meant to be derisive that is quite
literally what it is it is it is a
nutcracker which many are familiar with
but it's uh blue holding a pride flag
with a rainbow hat and then there's a
very happy I guess Yeti and unicorn and
then there's this image which depicts a
series of white and black Santa Clauses
in wheelchairs holding presence now okay
when I saw this I thought this is fake
okay it was like I think Sho on head
made a video 10 years ago a joke about
how diversity is going to result in a
trans non-binary you know person of
color in a wheelchair like that was a
joke she made and now I'm seeing this
image and so I I I I I said I don't know
about this and so I Googled it ladies
and gentlemen you can order your Santa
in a wheelchair holding gift Fabric and
they have the options of in black or
white and now look and it's already on
sale how much is it I can't see it uh $2
with like $7 shipping or something let's
find I $7 I almost want to buy a whole
bunch of them but I also kind of don't
just give them away company Christmas no
because I don't want to support it but
look if I was going to buy it it would
be like a novelty gag gift making fun of
wokeness they're selling them
legitimately and it's it's kind of it's
It's look if you are a a a other otherly
abled person of color and you would like
to purchase the Santa Claus then I'm
glad the exists for you I have no
problem with the free market providing
if there are people who have this lived
experience and they would like to be
represented on a Christmas tree then the
market shall provide but Target as a
massive uh I believe they're
multinational but a massive National
Corporation they're they're I know
Australia's Got a fake version that they
stole from us yeah but uh who are they
really selling to the answer is very
obvious white liberal women MH that's
who wants to buy this to show their
children look anyone can be anything at
any time it's uh what they call what um
impact it's like impact investment but
this is like the the the refu tunnel of
the impact investment it's impact sales
they're putting it out in the open for
people to see what they want them to
think about and they don't even care if
these things don't sell probably they're
this is this is so wrong I'm sorry this
is so wrong it's they're say people are
saying it's the black it's black
paraplegic Santa and I'm like this is
insulting to people okay they have
turned them into a joke and I thought
the best question of the night was
Lauren who asked how's he going to get
his wheelchair down the chimney right ex
doesn't make any sense I thought I
thought somebody was making fun of
Target making fun of veness and then I
was like it's real we need to put uh
those those ramps but in for Christmas
everyone needs to get a ramp on their
front door otherwise you're
discriminating it's the fake thing
that's a fake version of a guy that's
fake no you need a ramp up to your roof
y it's your CH but I mean the question
is like who specifically is the I mean
aside from like white liberal women but
it's like a very specific group of
people celebrate Christmas but also
really want to indulge in the wokeness
which I feel like is are we sort of
expecting a lot of um you know
paraplegic people to suddenly appear on
earth like why do we need so many of
them this could have been one Etsy
business that did really well but
instead Target is like everyone knows
someone in a wheelchair which feels more
like disturbing to me on some but that's
the thing like with all this woke stuff
whether it's paning to to women or to
Black people in wheelchairs who aspire
to be Santa it's not actually about the
group they're representing it's about
the activists who see it as a virtue
signal yeah I remember as a kid being
told that I could be Santa but it's just
a weird thing like you have to oh he has
to be just like me has to be in a
wheelchair too it's like well you know
you think be better flying around the
world if you have wheelchair and it's
about that time of year should we talk
have the Santa debate the Santa Santa
debate Santa is the Sant retired because
he's in a wheelchair now no no no listen
listen Okay Ian I know where you're
going with this do we tell kids if Santa
is real that's what I'm talking about
and I think there's a bigger question
now on top of
this I don't know that we can answer
that question until we answer the
question of how do you explain to
children that there is black paraplegic
Santa and white sis heteronormative
Santa no I'm I'm telling my kids the
only Santa is blacken in a wheelchair no
I'm going to take the FDR approach we're
going to hide the wheelchair we're going
to just like cover it up constantly no
the Scandal was that Santa was always in
a wheelchair they're regrowing
SP with people no now hold on I hold on
there where is where is Black Santa with
a Cocker implant mhm where he could be
wearing him he's got thick hair we don't
know we can't see perhaps where's trans
Santa yeah he's coming soon and that's
the horror that's the horror of the
season now which is like what are they
poor Santa who can't defend himself okay
so the Marvel's just came out right yeah
and it bombed it's the worst MCU opening
in in the Marvel franchise history and
it's because people just don't care for
these
woke
bad storylines where they just hamfist
in politics and when when people started
complaining back in the day about how
they like made an Bolin anolin played
like a black woman and people are like
yo I don't care about black actors
getting lead roles I care that you're
taking historical figures and characters
and changing their race like The Little
Mermaid South Park made a really great
point about this in the latest uh show
they did the panda verse the special
where PC principal is yelling at the
kids saying you just don't like black
people and they're like no we don't like
that you take an existing character and
turn into a black woman they were like
Miles Morales is awesome he's his own
character and has like an alternate
history storyline they gave him which we
understand like people like there's a
lot of superheroes that have same
superpowers as other
superheroes this is gone One Step Beyond
and they're now
taking I I I it's religious and
traditional figures and now race
swapping them and and like look I know
we've seen this because 10 years ago
there was an argument on Tumbl whether
or not bethoven was black and this is
what yes absolutely well is he no was he
of no of course not this is what they
tried doing they tried claiming that
Samus Aaron the game character was trans
so for those that aren't familiar Samus
Aaron is the star of the video game
Metroid the Metroid series and at the
end of the NES game if you like beat it
in the right way or whatever for the
credits it shows the character take the
helmet off and it's like super it's like
eight 8 bit or whatever but there's long
blonde hair like aha you played a woman
this whole time and I was like how about
this and Justin Bailey as your password
you can play as the woman oh Zero Suit
you get a the wave gun automatically you
start with it in the first one any in
Metroid in the first Metroid Justin
Bailey n yes yeah really wow and so what
happens then is a bunch of trans
activists started arguing well Samus
Aaron is 6'3 and you know like 180
pounds therefore that proves Samos was
actually trans and they tried they tried
doing these things they all they're
trying to do is rewrite cultural history
and take it over that's part of what is
happening right now with Target making
black paraplegic Santa mhm well I mean
sorry go ahead you go first well I was
going to say to this is a tangent at
this point but to Ian's question about
the whole Santa debate I'm actually very
anti- Santa because Santa is not a I
mean St Nicholas is a religious figure
but Santa the modern iteration of Santa
is basically just a way to shove
consumerism down our throats by people
who are not Christians who are
secularists and who only want to make
money do you think the people who had
designed that Santa are Christians who
celebrate Christmas nope do you think
all also I'm very against Santa movies
have you noticed that nowadays a
Christmas movie it's all about Santa and
gifts and a secular message it's a way
to undermine H channel hmark channel
it's about everyone ending up together
getting married it undermined the family
unit for me because it made me distrust
my parents not only did they lie to me
for 10 years yeah and then I found out I
was like what else are they lying to me
about it was terrible they would I I
didn't appreciate them every year around
Christmas when they would be the ones
that would bring me the gifts it it
should have been a bonding experience
for the family and that's this Soviet
communist uh consumer crap splitting up
the nuclear family yet again with now
your parent can't be the the hero this
year I think they're really interesting
ways to talk about Santa cuz I like the
like folklore aspect of it I think it's
fun to have like imaginative
opportunities for kids um I wouldn't
necessarily introduce this to your kids
but David sederis is the short story
author who has a really funny um essay
about at dinner parties he'll ask people
as an ice breaker and what does your
country tell you about Santa and it
changes and if you haven't heard it you
should definitely look it up it's really
funny uh I think it is interesting that
I grew up with uh the rert books where
which are like a British children's
series and Santa lives on a cloud and in
America we learn he lives in the North
Pole like there are ways to talk about
this in an interesting way it's just sad
that America Santa now is like you know
disabled I I care less about the skin
color so much as like what is he doing
how is he getting in his sled do we have
ADA accommodations at the North Pole you
know what I mean like it introduces a
level of bureaucracy to this like kind
of mystical story that like lots of
cultures tell um and it makes us seem
lame I will say the best is the the
Tibetan myth of Santa Claus where they
would every every winter their Yurts
would get covered up to the chimney and
they'd have to climb out the chimney and
go to the pine trees and they'd find
these mushrooms growing these white and
red amonita muscaria and the reindeer
would be eating them and they'd go and
they'd collect the mushrooms they'd come
back they'd CL climb down the chimney
and then hang the mushrooms up in socks
above the fire to dry overnight what and
then the next morning they boil them and
make tea with them every culture has
like
check out the myth of psychedelic Santa
it's crazy it's it's it's all the color
is the same it's the red and white myth
sorry to interrup from what I understand
the Orthodox Church they they have like
the Feats of St Nicholas that they
actually take pretty seriously so when I
say I'm anti-santa I'm not anti that but
I I don't support personally hat Santa
yeah I don't support modern consumerist
especially black wheelchair Santa who is
St Nicholas what' he do you know what
that is a good what is St Nichola was a
I don't know exactly where it was
somewhere in Eastern Europe is what they
think somewhere like turkey people have
said like the actual story comes from
you're right about the am mascaria stuff
from I've heard about that as well um
regarding like the the color like the
red and white and everything like that
but apparently like it had to do with
like he was a dude that went around and
helped some girl get dowy to get married
I think initially and that became Santa
supports marriage he's so trash this is
the best thing I've ever heard I sh this
Santa I'm I'm wondering what the lore is
as to how Santa became paraplegic I the
Imp chimney well if nose didn't go off
and he got bucked out of the sled that's
what I say like this is insulting to
people like the implication is that
Santa had some kind of terrible accident
or he's faking it's rough or he's just
getting older to get tips at the mall
maybe maybe I was going to go with he's
getting older you know he's got some
some arthritis in his knees from
climbing up and down the chimney so
maybe it's time to retire Santa and then
they'll introduce Mrs Claus or just call
her santet or
something I'm going to go with uh Santa
did a uh 720 on the mega ramp at and
then when he was going up for a varial
540 he clipped the coping and flipped
forward shattering his ankles and so
it's not a permanent thing and it's not
par he's not a paraplegic it's just that
he's got serious leg damage because he
was in the X Games last year this year
he's needs a wheelchair that's I like
that that makes it sound tougher I like
that version of American how about how
about Santa got shot down flying over
Eastern Europe that's more line I
thought you were going to say Santa did
911 are you going to blame Putin for
Santa's wheelchair injury that's rude
you could like merge all of the current
things right black Trans Santa is only
disabled because of actually Vladimir
Putin ordered Santa be shot down right
and that's why we have to send money to
Ukraine could be a rally around the flag
that finally makes sense
to this is what we thought at first but
new intelligent suggest it was
Hamas so now we've got to provide
funding for Israel uh did you guys grow
up with the Christmas movie uh Grandma
Got Run Over by a Reindeer it's like you
guys need to watch it immediately I
can't wait for the Christmas season yeah
like Santa killed the lady right what
well she's like in a hospital being
taken care of by elv don't spoil it for
people you guys get to watch it killed
the guy this Christmas season you should
check it out but it'll be like that
except it'll be like who shot Santa
Claus you know you you you never heard
the songs uh Grandma Got Run Over By
I've heard that song before like and
then they made a movie I guess I don't
know which came first yeah 199 movie
first the song is by Elmo and py from
1979 yeah the gag is that you can say
there's such thing as Santa but as for
me and Grandpa We Believe Grandma Got
Run Over by a Reindeer walking home from
my house Christmas Eve it's a classic
Christmas Tale yeah I thought everybody
knew that one you know put a little
Christmas cheer into this conversation
they figured out at Rice University how
to weave Nano threads carbon Nano
threads through broken severed spine and
then the spine finds itself in regrows
back together and they've got mice with
completely severed spines that are able
to walk again so what you're saying is
Santa may walk again yeah would you
rather have a Target insemination kit or
a Target paraplegic black Sanda for
Christmas just I'm just wondering I
would love to just like here's the
problem I would love to buy a thousand
of the black paric Santas to give us
gifts but to make fun of Target and
wokeness and the problem is I don't want
to give money to people who are serious
yeah you know if it was like the end
wokeness account announced they were
selling these things as jokes I'd buy a
bunch of them and give them out to
people but the fact that Target is
legitimately selling these things makes
me be like well I don't want to give
them money now if you bought it on Etsy
you pick up some of Lauren soap and then
some care Santas figured it out Target's
trying to play Both Sides mhm they know
that people who think it's hilarious
will buy it to make fun of them and
they're going to make money either way
people who genuinely support it will
also buy it Target is ultimately on its
own side with capitalism yeah the market
shall provide there is a market for us
to buy black PA pgic Santa because it's
a mockery of woke ideology and we think
it's funny I would just really like to
see uh photos from you know like
probably December 24th maybe you know
into January of people in their
clearance section at Target and see how
much these are selling for then well is
it is it that's where all their best
Progressive stuff goes or Lowe's where
they actually have the black blowup
Santas no how big they're like the the
big ones that you put on the front yard
oh wow I I saw I forget where we were
last year but I saw those and I was like
all right I likees jesus Wacky Waving
infatable arm flailing tub man well
Jesus you like no no the uh they do have
a dancing 58 in African-American dancing
Santa at Lowe's dancing Santa I bet the
dancing is good he's
I will I will buy both he's animatronic
not inflatable but maybe that's but
maybe they have more maybe all kinds of
stuff okay well ladies and gentlemen
it's not yet Christmas Thanksgiving is
uh in a week very exed and uh I do have
a Christmas present for all of you this
is from the post millennial Republican
wins ladden County Commonwealth Attorney
race against Soros funded incumbent
after Infamous gender neutral School
bathroom rape scandal now that headline
is a mouthful holy crap L county is
across street from us
um technically it's Riv yeah it's across
the river from us I say across street
but you know like it's down the street
you know it's down I mean technically
just it's right over the hill so it's
right there but uh so we know we
actually know a lot of people who are
who are involved with with what's going
on and it's a very mixed left and right
County but seeing this is actually
tremendous it's not the first time we've
seen Soros da get get you know basically
fired and uh it's just it's all around
good news I think we look at stuff like
this we take a look at the Marvel's
failing we take a look at Bud Light
failing we take a look at all these
things y'all we are winning the Marvel's
collapse hilarious I love that this
movie failed we are winning the culture
War people are waking up to this I had
the honor and privilege of meeting the
mother of one of the students at the
Lowden County High School that was
protesting males in the girls bathroom
and so we we had a good conversation
about it and and I was excited to meet
this this person uh her family has been
pushing back and speaking up and I'm
like this is exactly what we need now we
can see Lowden County maybe Paving the
way for pushing the stuff out what's
happening is you've got these Urban woke
people from DC moving Westward into the
more rural areas and trying to bring
their chaos with them but the people are
starting to resist and push it all back
so as we see all these crazy videos look
at this we got a bunch of these stories
here's one a group of brazen thieves
loot Amazon delivery truck as helpless
delivery driver looks on you've all seen
this they're just ransacking and I don't
know where this is where what the
location is I don't know if they say but
the point is we have we have a bunch of
examples of this here's one firefighters
attacked by mob after responding to
deadly car crash crime is out of control
and I don't know if it's that you know a
lot of people play these stats games so
they like crimes actually on the way
down but that doesn't take into
consideration what type of crime they're
referring to and could it be that the
reason crime is down is because people
are too scared to go outside or because
they made it legal like in San Francisco
you can rob 800 bucks and it's not
that's exactly it so in San Francisco
where they're like we're actually seeing
crime on the decline or people just stop
reporting it because they know it's not
going to be taken serious yep yeah I
think ultimately there is um I like
these stories about people winning and
doing something because it's so
discouraging when you're when you're in
San Francisco and your target has
nothing out because people keep
shoplifting I think it's one of the
doors that opens up well why don't I
just take something you know what I mean
and we like to see the representation of
a community saying no these are our
values and you assimilate to them or you
don't come here that was part of one of
the things I like about Ronda santis is
he stood up and was like if there are
looters they will be shot you will be do
not loot they will issue shooting on
command to anyone trying to loot and it
was like right away after a disaster
what was it a flood or something a
hurricane I think and no looting this is
the most important aspect of this
biberaj is notorious in lden County
that's the the the attorney for having
her office stick convictions for
disorderly conduct on Scott Smith the
dad who was arrested for confronting a
school board in June 2021 meeting after
his daughter was raped in a high school
in a female restroom by a biological
male in a skirt so let me just say this
guy his daughter is raped and he shows
up the school and he's Furious they end
up arresting him and this lady has him
criminally charged and now she is
fired feeling
good I would like to interview the new
who is it it's a lawyer the attorney
Commonwealth Attorney yeah Bob Anderson
cool how long's Bob Mr Anderson how long
is to Bob's current term I don't know
well that's a good move Bob what are you
going to do different do you think that
this is the kind of thing though that
and I'm this is a little bit cynical of
me where people will get excited about
this one race and then they'll forget
that they have to go out and be active
and do it in their Community complacent
yeah well the point is when you know
there's two factions on a field when one
side starts breaking and faltering you
don't say Okay pack it in guys you say
charge mhm and now now it is time to as
the the woke lunatics Retreat from the
the the hilltop of culture abandoning
movie franchises abandoning the stories
that we know and love we storm in and
plant our flag and replace what they
have tried to destroy this is a
legitimate route cultural route
sometimes when the enemy breaks you want
to let them flee because you don't want
to run into a potential trap but this is
not a potential trap this is legitimate
sea change right cuz hean seen the
Patriot with Mel Gibson good movie at
the end of the fight when the Cornwall
is like is that making the center and
then they're like they start running
away and then once they go over the hill
that's the Continental Army waiting to
trap them and then unloads on the
British yeah you know Hannibal did it to
the Romans they call it the hammer and
Anvil tactic where you you feain a
retreat and then they charge it and
that's your Anvil and then you come
around and flank them from behind is
your Hammer well I think this is if
nothing else proof that focusing on the
cultural issues they actually can change
policy and they actually have political
consequences because I don't know about
you folks but I often see especially
establishment conservatives Republicans
saying this isn't matter like this is
just too divisive we don't want to get
stuck in the weeds with this well
actually these are winning issues we see
that like parents go figure don't want
their kids to have to worry about sexual
assault in the locker room right they
they actually care about that can you
imagine yeah that'll get people out to
the polls and especially like we see how
motivated especially Suburban moms are
when it comes to the issue of like
what's happening in school so I think if
next year if Republicans are worried
about the Suburban mom vote we actually
need to keep hitting this issue we need
to go harder on it and not back away I
actually feel like one of the way they
could do that is by pushing like there
are a lot of states that have these laws
they'll get marketed or they'll get
written about as their um their
anti-gender affirming and whatever else
but really if you look at it a lot of
times they are people voting against or
judges overturning rules that say you
can't tell parents about what's going on
with their kids in school and I think
even Progressive parents would want to
know if their children are going by
different programs and it starts to be
like this unifying issue like if some if
a child makes a choice in school like
that any parent want to know you can't
decide arbitrarily who is dangerous and
who is not and who whose kids are secret
about this and you know you know what I
mean like there are ways to continue to
push this issue Lon county is so unique
because they had that specific case but
there are other parents who would get
behind I need to know what's going on
with my kids especially you know I think
is going to convince a lot of suburban
women to vote for the likes of Donald
Trump or at least someone more right
leaning is in the event that they have
uh male children explaining to them the
late 2010 history of the false
accusations mattress girl all of these
stories in the MEO movement and uh when
when you when you see this degree of
wokeness right now I think what's
worrying for mothers and fathers who
have daughters is this story about what
happens to this guy but what's what's as
worrying to a parent who has a male
child right the destruction of your
son's life because woke people can lie
about him a of racism bigotry assault or
otherwise and there will be no there
will be no due process there will be no
no innocent till proven guilty they will
destroy this person's life these are the
things we need to
stop mhm due process is
legit Inn it seems so basic to it until
proven guilty well I I I definitely
support you process but there's a
there's this also interesting tension in
a way between due process and freedom of
speech I I don't know if you guys are
familiar with Tommy Robinson but one of
the many legal issues that he's had in
the UK was reporting on uh I think it
was like a grooming gang forgive me in
comments if I get this wrong but
reporting on a grooming G trial and the
UK had it that there was a moratorium in
the Press because the official reason
was that they wanted due process they
didn't want these people's names
slandered if they were found innocent uh
people who are critical of it say
actually it's to basically hide the fact
that mass migration has led to an
increase in sexual assaults but what do
you guys think about kind of that issue
are we allowed to talk does that does
doe process after a certain point mean
that we need to clamp down on freedom of
the press if it means publishing these
allegations that are unfounded like Weil
T to deal with defamation slal and these
things the uh defamation liable slander
the problem is times V Sullivan and uh
uh in many ways there's pros and there's
cons to what's called anti-s slap
strategic lawsuits against public
participation basically anyone can say
whatever they want about anyone else so
long as they're all famous and it's
impossible to win a defamation case
impossible unless it falls into what's
called defamation per se
where you what you've said is so
shocking and egregious that damages
aren't needed and the defamation in of
itself warrants just you know Pursuit
like I guess the the issue would be if I
claimed Ian kicked a
dog well I don't know you know did I
know it was false is the question in
times V Sullivan and if Ian tried to
assume me claiming that it'd get thrown
out what if you claimed that I was
running a puppy mill and like
slaughtering animals and like not paying
my taxes you'd be like I mean that's
that's actually I I don't I don't even
think that would qualify like if if you
said I was a rapist then that would be
definition per se or that you had a
contagious disease but killing dogs
isn't enough nope probably not
contagious disease is one is there like
aist criminal criminal activity yes
there's a list it's criminal activity
contagious disease and something so
morally shocking and reprehensible or
whatever like calling someone a pedo is
defamation per se it's crazy I tried to
do the killing the dogs but it's just
not reprehensible enough I guess in this
Society dark yeah well because there are
act like Peta kills right it's true yes
they do right and so that's not
considered to be so morally outrageous
that it would be shocking to people to
claim because it's something that
happens there are kill shelters so if
you if you said that Ian was an evil
person who was running a puppy mill that
kills dogs they'd say okay well is that
an opinion statement about a puppy mill
we don't we don't know if this warrants
the you know a level of going to law
going to court over it yeah I think one
of the questions with freedom of the
press is you
know it is accurate to say this person
was was accused of this person's
standing trial for this and I understand
the sensitivity of the crimes and it's
people are evil they and I think this is
what we get from an untrustworthy press
right the fact that you would present it
as like it's a done deal no matter what
this is definitely they're not
presenting any other sides they have
decided there is a narrative and they're
going to follow it through even if they
might throw the word in allegedly a
couple times it's not on recording Nancy
Pelosi's husband Paul accused of getting
into a fight with a male prostitute over
a drug deal gone wrong
and of course people are going to be
like okay well hold on we know that
story that's a big leap I didn't say it
was true and I didn't say I said it I
said he was accused of it that's a fact
statement so if I report that Paul
Pelosi was accused of getting into a
fight with a gay prostitute then that is
a factual fact statement that is a that
is a true statement he was accused of
that by a whole bunch of people on the
internet doesn't mean it's true I never
said it was true I said he was accused
of it that's a fact and and what's
really tricky with journalists is that
they really only need one person to make
that accusation to be able to write that
headline exactly but realistically
should be someone in the legal system
making a a a legitimate like an official
accusation which would be Char they are
activist attorney generals everywhere
who will Levy all kinds of stuff against
you I mean one of the I'm allowed to
accuse Joe Biden of of taking bribes and
I think everyone's going to agree like
yeah he probably did there's no official
govern government determination so far
uh members of the Republican Party have
presented evidence where that they say
asserts this but it's not been like
adjudicated I think we're still allowed
to come out and say that he is a corrupt
mfer who is taking breads when I look at
the word accuse the definitions all all
the definitions are to charge with a
shortcoming to charge formally to make a
charge of wrong so if you're not
charging them literally that means you
don't have the legal Authority it's not
technically an accusation I mean mean if
someone go It also says to claim that
someone has done something wrong you can
get a little vague the thing is if I
accuse someone of doing something or if
someone is like charges are brought
against someone theoretically if you're
being ethical you present evidence that
might contradict the point that seems
obvious like if the government says you
know you burned down a building I would
potentially say there were other people
and I would get a statement from you if
you're trying to present information
honestly you're supposed to represent
multiple points of views and
possibilities but that's not really how
it works anymore but it doesn't matter I
mean the definition of accuse is to
claim someone has done something wrong
yeah that's it I guess maybe there could
be an official accusation like a capital
A and that's like when it's a legitimate
accusation from like someone with
authority as opposed to all this
nonsense being slung the issue is people
are evil the issue is as a culture we
used to have Scruples and people were
like I can't lie in the newspaper like I
feel so bad I'd be scared like what how
could I couldn't get away with that now
everyone's just like I don't care what
happens to you I'm going to do whatever
I want yeah and and in our defamation
cases the victim has to prove malice
that that person acted with the
intention of destroying your reputation
which if you were to be like hey New
York Times you printed something false
about me and they could be like whoops
we didn't know SL we didn't do it slash
we don't care then you can't prove what
Happ extremely difficult you go to court
and you say they defamed me and they'll
file a motion to dismiss under anti-s
slap legislation or times whatever and
the judge has to then agree Discovery is
warranted so you have to provide some
evidence they may have like you this is
the crazy thing in order to actually sue
you actual M standard in times be Solon
is that the person doing the the LI liel
or slander knew what they were saying
was false which means if someone in the
Press lies or here's my favorite if
someone tweets a thing and it was a joke
a news organization can take that run it
as fact and then say Oh but we thought
it was
real how how do you prove that they knew
that it wasn't a paper trail that will
almost never exist internal
Communications where they're like well
gee I know this is not true but run it
anyway which exactly would never exist
almost yep but civil Tor not criminal
yeah so I guess you get what you get but
you know I guess going back to the main
story we got we got to Jiu-Jitsu this
because false accusations can bring down
Nations if like you like the Soviet
Union would go around accusing people
accusing people accusing people take
them away without a without a trial or
any kind of process it reminds me of
America today and it's kind of annoying
because technically it is your you're
not allowed to like make a false police
report or anything like that but when it
comes to like all of these like me too
cases or even just the run-of-the-mill a
sexual assault allegation with that
results in a charge where the man is
found innocent or not guilty you would
think that if if there's a person coming
saying that this person like assaulted
me and the man is then then found not
guilty then that should in all of those
cases uh lead to some sort of
Investigation into a false police report
but that almost never happens MH some
people suggest that the accuser serves
the sentence that the the accused would
have served if they find out that it was
a false accusation I think I mean I
definitely think that there should be
some sort of legal punishment for trying
to ruin someone's life vindictively and
using weaponizing the legal system I
think it should be worse so if
somebody's accused uh like if a guy
commits sexual assault and the and and
the charge is going to be like 10 years
or something then if it's a false
accusation it should be 15 the reason
being uh it was it's one thing for
someone to commit a crime and then have
the government the law enforcement and
the and the court system seek to uh
bring some kind of justice and stop this
person as an offender all of that is a
legitimate practice if the person is
falsely accusing someone two crimes are
being committed one against law
enforcement and the government and one
against the individual who's falsely
accused and so we we seek deterrence we
don't want people to try and use law
enforcement as a weapon against people
through false accusations so that's an
enti separate crime so they should serve
the sentence of the person of what would
have been for the person they accused
and they should get an additional charge
over the manipulating and falsifying
government you know blah blah blah blah
blah the only prominent example I can
think of of someone getting their just
deserts for trying to weaponize the
legal system is jce mlet what happened
barely I mean but he at least there was
a trial thing he ended up like you know
it was a nothing Burger but still there
was at least I me when was the last time
you remember someone being charged with
B like lying and leading police on he's
still to this day is maintaining it
really happened he he did an interview
with uh was it Charlemagne I think it
was and he was like this what they said
and he was like really like yeah he's
like okay yeah but what else is he gonna
do honestly he's got to go down with
that chip because if if he admitted it
was wrong it's almost worse for him if
he admitted right away he'd be back by
now if right when it went down he said
look we were trying to bring awareness
and we were trying to you know make
people so performance art piece no he he
could have said me and my friends
decided to Stage this because we felt
like other stories of other victims
weren't getting any national attention
and only a celebrity could bring to
light the injustices that were happening
I regret what we did I'm sorry I
deceived everybody and I accept the
punishment yeah and then like he's going
to jail or whatever his charges are I
guess that's what he's really scared of
he doesn't want to be a felon
but we are years past this now and
people would be like oh okay and
seriously his his PR team should have
said own it and claim the issue is like
here's what I if I was a PR guy for tet
I'd immediately do a Google search for
some kind of racist hate crime and then
I would have Justice me be like when I
saw this story and that no one cared I
knew the only way to get the attention
of the press was for a high-profile
celebrity to do it so that's why I
decided to Stage this event and I regret
it or or you could say like I stage it
to bring attention to this case now that
oh yeah now that everyone's talking
about what you should tell talking
exactly I'm coming forward I'm going
ahead and getting in front of it I want
you all to know now this didn't happen
to me but it did happen to this person
should been on his crisis team it would
have been way more based if he came out
and said like right away like yes I am
jce mlet I have staged this hate crime
why every year over 800 false hate
crimes are reported and people are lying
every single day then that everyone on
the right would have been like oh wow B
he's really uh checkmated us here I
don't know what to do with that right I
mean one of the complaints that that
Chicago had was that he wasted resources
right so that was follow him but maybe
he would just make a nice donation to
cover the cost of his you know false
allegations there is a way to spin this
I think part of it is that he liked
being you know celebrated as his victim
and I think that kind of attention is
very hard toel especially since I don't
think he'll really act again at this
point yeah I wonder I wonder where he is
now especially with the Israel Palestine
stuff because like there are a lot so
there are a lot of celebrities that
hitch their wagons to the woke left and
now they're regretting it could you
imagine being Justice mlet and
destroying your entire career over this
attempt at like anti-trump nonsense only
to find out that you're on the wrong
side of whatever this is like he's in in
the entertainment industry a lot of the
people who are running it are going to
be more pro-israel and then all the
leftists who would have supported him in
the in in if his hate crime worked were
going to be anti-is Pro Palestine so
it's like good luck buddy at least for
Ethan Klein he can get up and leave the
room Ryan long did a great skit about
that the actor not knowing whether to
post Pro Palestine or pro Israel it's
incredible he always had a you know I
said it before I'll say it again it must
be a horrible way to live to be on the
left yeah oh my gosh I almost fell into
it man in La I was an actor until I was
like 27 and it was just shredding my
soul and then when I got into when
YouTube appeared I was like you can I
can actually speak my mind and and I can
make a career out of it the modern
version of the left right it's it's
really simple for people like me and
many others who are like quote unquote
disaffected liberals or post liberal or
whatever where it's just like we
maintain our positions and we don't care
about what the left wants to do and so
we get excised we get kicked out and
it's like whatever I don't care screw
you guys but I have to imagine the
people like Ethan Klein who decided I'm
just going to agree with whatever
they're saying that dude must be
stressed out for the past month and a
half since the Hamas thing happened and
everybody on his show is just screaming
in his face and calling him a Zionist
Pig he's probably thinking like it's the
end the right will not have him he's
he's a shill he's sold out you know and
the left hates his guts because he's
he's like pro Israel and it's not just
that he was trying to Hitch his wagon to
the left he chose Hassan perer and to
try and Le like that is not just the
left like that is some of the most like
radical like literal Communists out
there that you get I got I got to pull
this clip up I got to pull this clip up
let me see if I can find it just cuz
it's from a little while ago but I think
it just needs to be talked about I'm
endlessly fascinated by these let's play
this this is a this is a clip from uh
The Leftovers podcast Hassan and
uh Ethan Klein I this is a a Twitter
account uh it's just at Dan I don't know
who runs the account it seems you know
Anonymous but uh I'm going to play this
clip for you guys Al Indians and this is
going to sound very radical and possibly
very violent but this is a matter of Law
and maybe even if you agree with this a
matter of morality Palestinians uh have
the the legal ground to violently seize
back their own homes from the settlers
this is a reality and that is precisely
the reason why they have to exist under
endless occupation in the and that's why
I say if it was settlers that would be a
lot more understandable but let's not
off skate okay I understand what you're
saying but this dude just called babies
militants no I understand and there are
baby settlers as well but there are baby
settlers as well there are babies in the
settlements but the babies they killed W
they were not I know okay so no hold on
let me can can we just I'll play that
one more time for you occupation of you
and that's why I say if it was settlers
that would be a lot more understandable
he says Hassan says Palestinians have a
right to violently seize back the land
that was taken by settlers then Ethan
Klein says yes if it was settlers but
this guy's saying babies and Hanan goes
but some of the babies are settlers
basically saying this there is
justification for the killing of babies
uh like this is Hassan perer is pure
audience capture this is what he
represents
he says whatever is going to get favor
among the people who are chatting to him
and that that's all it is he like what
what it what the the left is rather
insulting like they're rather
condescending to him too
but this is abject evil well I mean on
questionably to play Devil's Advocate we
don't know what comes after that so what
I'm what I'm hoping Hassan does is
explain that that wouldn't be justified
therefore the Israeli targeting of
Palestinian babies is also not justified
in light of the October 7th attacks
that's what I'm hoping came after that I
don't
know sh like no because look at the yel
professor said settlers are not
civilians yeah I I really I I agreed
agreed agreed if in fact the longer clip
in the full context shows Assan say
there is no excuse ever for killing
babies and I recognize that then okay
for for the sake of just this we will be
very clear in that regard Hassan calling
babies settlers while justifying Hamas
killing settlers is a horrifying thing
in of itself and I hope I hope he's
clarified later on that that's that's he
does not support the killing of babies
and I almost never say this but I feel
for Ethan uh over the the past few weeks
the clips I've been seeing because Ethan
is I would say very moderate especially
for an Israeli about the situation he's
actually donated money to help
Palestinians uh he acknowledges that he
does not support Israeli settlement so
that's not like you know where they're
actually like getting you don't think he
is Ethan Klein was an edgy boy on the
internet who made crude jokes way way
back in the day you don't think he's mod
on the isra no I don't I think that he
hitched his wagon to the left because
many so he's not a political guy he
knows nothing of politics he's thrust
into this because Donald Trump and the
culture wars turned politics into pop
culture so now if you're somebody if you
you look at his original YouTube channel
where he did silly jokes it was in Decay
it was falling apart he launches a
podcast Channel and now it's more
conversations he has Jordan Peterson on
his show and they're having a great
conversation why it was in it was it was
in it was trendy it was the thing to do
the intellectual dark web then as things
start splitting more seriously in the
culture War he decides he's going to go
left what does he do he tweets Jordan
Peterson's not a good guy so I'm going
to take the episode Down The Only Reason
Ethan Klein comes out and acts moderate
on Israel is because he's desperately
trying not to get cancelled by the left
so you think he's do you think he's a
Zionist and hiding it no no no no no but
I think he's probably somewhat
pro-israel he outright said Hamas is
lying the left believes outright Hamas
propaganda and uh historical revisionism
his wife is Israeli and again I'm pretty
sure she was in the IDF was veteran is
it confirmed though we for sure for sure
100% IDF veteran and so he's thinking
like sure I mean he's he may not be a
Zionist but he's certainly like yeah
Israel like he's pro-israel yeah he's
been there so he comes out says I'm
going to donate to to Palestinians and
stuff because his entire audience is
this but that's why I feel bad for him
because he is trying to I mean in this
one regard he is trying to I guess like
be as I don't know Building Bridges as
as much as he can but they're still not
accepting it if can't help but feel for
him in that let me let me just stress
there have been many times in the show
where Ian and I have been mad at each
other and we've we've gone at it I would
not ever sit down next to a person who
says yeah but babies are settler I'd be
like are you nuts you're not going to
sit right here and tell me you think
killing B I'll take it up to the edge of
that but no because like in Vietnam
seven-year-olds had grenades and baskets
and they'd walk up to the American
Soldier and then they'd blow them up so
they had to start shooting seveny but
babies are they don't move they just lay
there you take them captive at the very
least lay there they they lay there they
cry and Ethan kleene is sitting there
actually having a discussion with this
guy and the fact that the show didn't
stop on the spot when he said that I
would have been like no no no no no tell
me right now you are not saying what you
are saying Ethan's just like well I mean
come on and they go back and forth a
little bit I I'm I'm sorry I think Ethan
Klein saw his his waning internet
presence and decided I got to choose a
side I'm going to go with the left
because that's what celebrities are
doing and that's what I get guess we do
because it was not a principle based
decision nor a knowledge based one you
take a look at when Steven Crowder
wanted to have a conversation with Ethan
so what did Ethan do brought in Sam
Cedar and totally pulled a stunt because
he is not a political guy and even says
it then why the is he doing leftovers
anyway well congratulations dude you had
an opportunity to sit with Jordan
Peterson and have a conversation with
someone who is very moderate open and
understanding Jordan Peterson's famous
interview with I think it was Jim Jeff
where Jeffrey says do you think the
government should mandate you know that
people provide service he goes no he
goes what about black people like civil
rights and Jordan Peterson goes you know
maybe I was wrong about that because
he's a smart rational guy and Ethan
Klein had that opportunity and could
have gone that middle of the road route
where he says y'all are crazy chill out
I'm going to talk to who I want to and
believe what I want to believe instead
he told people like us like Jordan
Peterson to f off your bigots and racist
and misogynists and he hitched his wagon
to people who are who are calling him a
Zionist Pig celebrating Hamas I'm not
saying P I'm drawing the distinction and
a dude who quite literally said but
babies are settlers that's what Ethan
Klein decided to buy into
congratulations buddy this is what you
this is what you you you reap your so
Mike wonder is like Ethan I I feel like
what's up dude uh your intelligence is
probably like a 12 like it's not super
high or like a little bit it's like
above average intelligence but kazi's
charismatic dude like he's he's got
Charisma but like the intellect isn't
like top level genius so I don't I'm not
drawn to like connecting with him I like
to talk with Scientists but that doesn't
mean that we leave people like that
behind like he's so influential in
society I want to help him I think this
is a really interesting um internet
friend ofies moment to have because I
think it's actually probably what's
going to happen when many Progressive
families assemble for Thanksgiving right
that they're going to have to look at
each other and instead of it being like
conservative Uncle yells at you know
Progressive isra baby and it's going to
be people who think they're on the same
side these Generations that look apart
and say like but why are you saying this
thing and I can't and and like I think a
lot of people have this moment where
saying they'll have sort of extremist
rhetoric brought to them like this like
the justification of how and if and when
you should potentially harm children in
this conflict obviously answer is never
uh and have to confront these people
they think they have everything in
common with I think this is a really
interesting moment of Reckoning and I
think because these are well-known
personalities you can see where the
bifurcation is but people are going to
experience this in their real lives very
soon right and I mean just this past
month alone I've seen Ethan Klein cry on
camera at least twice really yeah oh
yeah get up from the stream I saw that I
was crying oh yeah well and that's why I
think this is also why I feel bad for
him I don't think he's being as
calculated or at least not to this he
was he actually broke down in tears
talking about a video he saw of a a
Palestinian father clutching his dead
child yeah when he was talking to Assan
that got me too I mean obviously it was
terrible and like I think he is someone
who is ultimately an empathetic person I
don't think he's evil and I think he is
seeing the horrors of this war but it
you can't deny that yeah he has he this
is his bed and he's he's been trying to
C capitalize on these people who are now
turning on him because obviously they
would eventually it's the banality of
evil it's that when he deleted that
Jordan Peterson episode and then
publicly condemned Jordan Peterson I'm
like yeah that was the weakest yeah that
that's that that is when when you see
that photo of all the people doing the
Roman salute to Hitler and the one guy's
angrily like no that's the Defiance that
we respect the person who says I am not
going to just do what these people are
saying he was the guy doing the salute
he was just one of those other people
who was like I'm just going to do
whatever they tell me to do because I
don't want to I don't want to get ryant
on his community for social surrounded
by evil surrounded by evil people who
would like listen if you if you are
someone who thinks that Israel is taking
it too far and they're killing too many
civilians I hear you if you're someone
who thinks Hamas went too far and they
started this on October 7th granted the
fight's been going on for Generations
then I hear you if you're going to sit
there and say but babies are settlers
like dude you you are way past that
point I have no idea there's that line
itself is insane even if after the fact
he says all right I get it babbe it
shouldn't die or whatever but like the
babies are settlers means he intended to
to get to that point morally yeah for
real and it that's I've been kind of
blackpilled on Twitter because I've seen
people kind of argue also that well the
the Palestinian babies it's it's
basically just a future terrorist that's
being killed oh Absol it's nut I feel
just in general the past month I've seen
the worst of Humanity on social media on
both sides the people calling uh uh the
individual who said The only reason not
to Nuke Gaza is that the Fallout would
would impact Israelis Bethany Mandel
yeah insane that's like derangement that
is that is a degree of psychotic evil I
just
but look always when everyone's just
like Israel this palestin that I'm like
I'm the United States like I don't know
why we're involved in that so I'll leave
it there the point is though when it
comes to left versus right in this
country and and the fight we're seeing
and the breakdown of the left dude Ethan
could have a lot of people said like why
did he go into this leftist camp where
you can't be funny and you have to be
walking on eggshells he was always like
this edgy dude who made offensive jokes
he interviewed Jordan Peterson he used
to say I I you can't even say him on
YouTube he used to say several racist
and homophobic slurs on his show
famously a fairly long compilation clip
out there of all the slurs that he's
dropped on his channel over the years
and he decided I better align with these
people who hate my guts right
congratulations paying him I me that's
the thing he he might be empathetic he
might have emotional attachment but this
is like his business now is to be saying
the right thing to the right people and
I can't imagine going exactly like
there's there's nothing he can do to
change it and I think in some ways would
be more interesting to see a version of
this where there's principle there's
principle behind it saying like well you
know I believe this but you guys
whatever or I have these certain
standards but he compromises himself and
I don't really follow his stuff that
intensely but he repeatedly compromises
what you think could be his value and
that means that ultimately he's he is to
be bought although I can't this is the
most praise I've ever given Ethan Klein
I've done several hit pieces on him in
terms of videos on my channel but I I
have liked that him and Hassan have they
did a debate on capitalism versus
communism strangely enough Ethan Klein
was debate uh I guess defending the
capitalists he's not a capital he's more
like a Social Democrat but at least you
know some Market competition that was
interesting and he he and Assan did have
a sit down where they both talked about
their perspective on Israel Palestine
and I thought at least that exchange of
ideas where they both clearly were were
trying to remain friends through that I
thought that was useful and especially
when it comes to Israel Palestine it's
not just the left that's having this
like internal breakdown the right is too
right because you do have the neocons
and the more dissident anti were
populist right and we're having our own
Schism as well M oh yeah Ben Shapiro
calling Candace owens's disgrace right
or saying that the Things She Said are
disgraceful right even though Candace
has been very consistent that she's she
wants to worry about America and
basically all she tweeted out was that
government should not engage in genocide
which if you believe that Hamas is the
elected government of Palestine is also
applicable to to both sides dude I'm
concerned with having American aircraft
carriers over there like what I keep
being told about the USS Liberty that's
something with the the Israeli
government you should you should be
careful about that one uh allegedly the
Israeli Air Force jet fighter aircraft I
mean they did end up paying out the
American government so I'm concerned
like false flag operation like a missile
comes out of Gaza and hits one of our
aircraft carers but it was actually
Israeli missile I don't want we should
get out of there it doesn't let me stop
you there it doesn't matter where the
missile comes from if a missile comes
out of the Middle East in any capacity
and hits a US Target who everyone will
claim it was exactly what they want it
to be exactly the US military will say
Iran did it the pro Palestinians will
say Israel did it the the uh uh the
pro-israel will say Hamas did it yeah if
it comes out of a foreign country other
than Israel then it'll be like hard to
deny it doesn't matter where it comes
from they the US will say Iran did it
right when when when the well if it
comes out of Tel Aviv it's going to be
hard to sell that but I Pro it came out
of Tel Aviv how do you know you read in
the news I mean exactly and you were
going to get American intelligence
agencies going to news organizations
saying tell them it came out of I don't
think the Americans want their carrier
to be hit as a false flag maybe the USS
Liberty thing was an accident probably
that's the controversy over it is that
the Israeli government claims it was an
accident but Joo willink I think
interviewed some survivors who say that
they don't think it was an accident so
was it a false flag that's why people
talk about it did America get involved
in the 1967 war after that the no
because it ended up it ended up being
really short but we are we're going to
go to super chats so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and
head over to timcast click join us if
you'd like to hang out in the uncensored
members only show coming up at 10: p.m.
where you can submit questions and
actually talk to us and our guest it's
going to be a lot of fun and also the
infringed documentary is available now
you definitely need to see it and share
with your friends of course our first
super chat comes from Clint Torres who
says howdy people Clint Torres of course
sounds like a good nickname to me howdy
Clint I shot for a second today did I
get it you did not you got
First's trying to be second he's still
first wow no one to fold him alfha
turkey says Ian the Canaanites were
Phoenicians who like the farle worship
moik that's hot data is that is that
true I don't know I'd have to reference
it Alex Conrad says you should invite
nerd rodic on the culture war that is a
very good suggestion and we will is that
Gary yeah he's
spectacular uh one evil chef says darmok
when the walls fell yeah that's exactly
how I feel yeah what there there were
several other key phrases if you guys
remember them put reference
Tre oh yep it was a a culture that could
only speak in uh in like
stories oh so they would convey all of
their ideas by saying a phrase from a
story so like a society of old people no
I don't know it just I don't know how it
would actually function but the people
are like shrugging like when the walls
fell when the walls and it's like what
are you saying and they're like in their
mind it conveys the full idea of what
they're trying to explain in the context
what do we got Ram g stany j says Tim at
Great risk I tell you this I'm fixing a
ram on your skateboard when I get an
atomic elbow from the top ropes I wake
up to Ian ripping his shirt off flexes
so hot says you tell Tim you do you do
you leftist I have no idea what you mean
that Ray G Stanley you tell you de left
is he typing with his elbows he might
have been actually what the heck no but
I will rip my shirt off dude I imagine
it must have been with the
elbows all right let's grab some more
Super
chats the are KN says in reference to
yesterday's guest un house imply
something was taken away this is leftist
manipulation to evoke an emotional
response I think the reason they started
saying unhoused is the implication that
everyone should have a house communism
yeah because you could call them stray
stray humans they've strayed from the
path but that doesn't mean they supposed
to have a house homeless could imply
like home uh uh what what what what is
what is the the poem um a home is where
your family is a house is you know a
container or something like this and so
when when you say someone's homeless
you're saying they don't have anywhere
to safe sleep safely the left is trying
to
distinguish or not distinguish uh uh
well yes they're they're trying to make
a distinction
between there could be someone who lives
in a shack that's their home and their
family's there but it's not a house and
so they're unhoused which means they
should have a house were you guys
talking about the San Francisco cleanup
for yeah yep and I said why are you
saying un housed I I find it offensive
as someone who's actually done uh work
with homeless shelters and trying to
help homeless people it is offensive to
call them
unhoused uh I just it's it's lce
nonsense it's also inaccurate because it
assumes that if you just give them
shelter then the problem is gone which
is what they're trying to do but you
still have that basically plethora of
likely problems including addiction
maybe mental illness that will follow
them I think I I I genuinely here's
here's a here's a problem that we face
you know when I talked to the likes of
Steven Marsh and he said says that you
know you're you're right or you're
biased or whatever and I'm like no dude
you just don't know what you're talking
about and how do I tell you that I'm
actually not biased I just am telling
you the truth and there in lies the
issue so I have my biases of course I'm
Pro 2A however my position on 2A is
rooted in how do you have a functioning
system of governance that has a
constitution and constitutional
guaranteed rights and then one faction
trying to vote away those rights like
you can't do that it's not a question of
whether I think you should have guns
it's a question of whether or not
someone has the right to take them away
from you they don't the system is here
the rules are in front of us play by the
rules that's not bias that's me saying
oh okay maybe maybe there could be good
effective gun laws you can't do it
because the Constitution says no so they
lie cheat and steal if I'm talking with
uh someone like Steven Marsh and he says
there are more seditionist seditionists
on the right than on the left I said
what's your metric for this he goes
court cases then I bring up the fact
that where are the criminal charges from
the sum of Love riots comparable to
January 6 where the criminal charges
from 529 in front of the White House the
fire B by the White House he didn't even
know about it and I'm like so it's not
an issue me being biased dude I'm not
saying the right or the left has more or
less I'm saying what's your metric and
you don't have one this is the problem I
think when you look at people on the
left who believe uh uh insane things
it's because they're genuinely ignorant
but angry and then when you look to the
right you do have that but the tendency
on the right is more mature calm and
rational that's just it plain and simple
that's why there are post liberals who
are now in line with conservatives on on
the issue on the issue of say like Trump
and America first because we act because
reality has a right-wing bias when I was
on the left I was obsessed with mob
getting a lot of people to believe what
I believed that was my goal now I want
the merits to live on their own when I'm
gone I still want that idea to be
present I care benevolent cult leader
yeah you got to get away from the cult
and build systems that let people govern
themselves because other it's too easy
to become a cult leader with this
technology so the so the issue is in
reference to this one uh Aaron said we
should build houses for the unhoused and
give them places to live and I said okay
and then who's going to maintain that
house because many of these people when
I mentioned that probably 80% of
homeless people choose to be homeless he
was shocked and didn't believe it and
I'm like it's it's actually really
simple arithmetic if I woke up to a
person and say do you enjoy being
homeless say no I say would you like to
not be homeless they say yes would you
like a job yes congratulations they were
homeless for two days and now they're
not homeless anymore this is why when
you see a homeless person it is almost
entirely likely they are choosing to be
homeless because if they didn't want to
be homeless they would seek these
nonprofits and get out of that situation
he was shocked by this but something
that is encouraging is that you're
you're right and also there's a high
percentage of homeless people who are
only transiently homeless like they
don't remain homeless in the United
States uh which is very encouraging
because it is it is a country where you
actually are able to reach that rock
bottom and then build your way back up
but my point is not to be uh uh specific
not to specifically focus on
homelessness my ISS my point is the left
gives you these surface level
nonsensical positions and then demands
them with rage MH and they're like there
are more empty houses than homeless
people and I'm like yes but the solution
to homelessness is not putting people in
a in a in an empty house they'll burn
the place down they'll destroy it
they'll get injured these are people who
are unwell and incapable of maintaining
and sustaining a house how oh man Libya
was on the show and and I was like this
is coming from people who never owned
houses before cuz it is a lot of work
and then Libya was mentioning like oh
yeah when I have a problem I'm like I
can't call the anymore yeah yeah when
you rent you just call the super the
superintendent and they come and fix
your problem for you it reminds me of
that show um Extreme Home Makeover where
they would be like you're a family we're
going to you have some good story and
we're going to demolish your house we're
going to build you this really fancy
house but often those houses were um
incredibly they needed a lot of
electricity they need a lot of water
they need they need to be maintained
they were the most expensive house in a
neighborhood that really didn't sustain
that and so it was ultimately a
financial burden in a lot of cases and I
think that is sort of the this position
we're putting some people into to that
they don't want to be a part of the
system so to speak they don't want to
pay rent or pay deal with any of stuff
they have their own own ways of living
and forcing them into it doesn't always
work and they've done studies about the
amount of money per homeless people per
homeless person that places like San
Francisco spent and it's absolutely
astronomical I mean it's like you're
talking about 100 Grand exactly so you
you actually like a a upper middle class
salary being spent on a single homeless
person who is still not living well so
like not only do they not have the
solutions to it but there's what they're
trying to do is actively bad and I get
that from a compassionate standpoint
they don't want to see homeless people
on the street suffering but I'll again
bring up that sack most people who are
homeless do not remain homeless for the
entirety of their lives so you know
they're they're treating homelessness
like a I guess like a disease that
someone just has and will have forever
they will never again be I guess able to
support themselves which is the wrong
way to look at it let's uh read this
from IO fam he says Tim if you love guns
read this state court ballot measure 114
verdict coming by 1122 was the sole
attorney versus 8 from from the state it
is the strictest gun law in the country
and it's getting very little attention
uh State what state yeah I was going to
say what state is I don't know where you
are sir so uh I'm assuming Illinois
maybe or something I don't know
yeah we'll grab some more Super
chats where are we at wful Sensei says
how often do advert advertisements for
infringement come up daily for lefties
everywhere on the internet I have found
that including Lauren Southern's name in
searches forces the ABC algo to show the
document first on Google uh I have no
idea I don't know we got uh I think
three ads running right now for
infringed is that what you meant
advertisements were infringed on yeah
they were wondering about the analytics
I have no idea I don't know Tim's got
people for that he doesn't need to know
about yeah but like we do not have a
massive marketing apparatus like a lot
of companies where we're tracking at all
we're just
like spending the ads promoting the idea
of gun rights in and of itself is the
victory so we're hoping that in the end
the bottom line
you know it works out and the
documentary gets a lot of views so there
you go T-Rex pet pet shop says
establishment Republican voters really
don't know what's happening in this
country I call them Fox News reps who
only know what the establishment wants
them to know that's why they're mad at
Maga for firing Kevin McCarthy but don't
know why Lauren do you have pets I do I
have a leon burger whose name is Jelly
Bean and she is beautiful like it's
actually when I take her out in public
it's almost a nuisance because I get
stopped so often by people just in a
she's about 145 lbs wow those dogs are
amazing yeah she's a great
dog jaffo on the bound says you think
our Founding Fathers didn't freaking
come to blows on the senate floor or
dueling out back make dueling great
again and back up the Bluster uh yeah
dueling was like all the rage this is
like super vintage Jackson dueled a lot
of people the idea was that you would
defend your honor but not try to
actually kill the guy so often what
duels would be is they'd say sh I want
to duel you and they would draw pistols
and then aim away and fire and then both
their honor was intact because they both
shut up to a duel risking life but
didn't kill each other and then uh I
think it was uh it was Alexander
Hamilton and Burr and that's what
happened yep Burr did not care and
Hamilton was like I will aim away and B
was like I'll kill you yeah yep fired
away and then he got hit and he diad
there's not many stories about them
fighting on the the floor of the
Congressional uh there was the caning
Continental Congress what did they what
happened the the the caning between it
was a it was a what was it it was a uh
Democrat who caned uh no no it was a
republican who got caned by a Democrat I
did they hold him down and he was like
caning him on the on the ground start
bashing him in the face with a cane and
and caused a a traumatic brain injury oh
my God is that what it was it was a it
was a a Democrat no no no who was it was
there look who
caned what I'm typing in the search I
think it was a a a it was before guy got
caned like a m was the guy from used to
go to work carrying pistols and Bowie
knives yeah mhm sometimes use them on
colleagues it says that's from
history.com yeah I don't know I think
people in chat will it's been a while
since I read about it I think it was a
guy from Massachusetts got mercilessly
it was Preston Brooks entered the
chamber carrying the cane I imagine he
was the he walked over to Senator
Charles Sumer the pro slavery oh no Pro
the pro slavery Southerner was the guy
with the can right yeah he s and whacked
him in the head with the can and Su was
Massachusetts uh it doesn't say beat him
un republican from Massachusetts right
right walked out and no one stopped it
everyone just stood there and watched
and in the South they cheered for it and
said the north was lying about the
seriousness of the injuries and in the
north they were like they caused him to
have serious brain damage for a long
time wow yeah and leading up to the
Civil War say in the three decades there
were more than 70 violent incidents
between congressmen wow so are you
saying that we're leading up to a civil
war not with Bernie Sanders in charge
that's true he's going to break up all
those hallway
fights what do we got Zack rammer says
love the work you guys are doing
building culture and winning the culture
War I'm sending the Super Chat in
celebration of my first born child
Stetson being born keep up the great
work you guys are doing uh
congratulations great glad to hear it
happy birthday ston yeah congrats good
job having a family I'm Pro that as is s
the Hallmark
Channel all right OMG puppy says Senator
McCarthy spoke at the Oxford Union he
came across as a neocon Warhawk and a
narcissist unsurprising his mask is off
The Clapper of cheeks has play the audio
recording from the reporter I don't
think they actually published that I
don't know if that was out at the time I
know that she said she chased after with
the microphone but I don't know if also
would you necessarily hear that like if
someone just comes and like right you'd
hear him saying like why'd you hit me
yeah but that's pretty much you wouldn't
see it yeah all right Paul tascal says
eight suspects ages 13 to 17 arrested in
the last Vegas school beating death all
being charged with murder and will be
tried as adults according to report
interesting I'd like to see the full
details a lot of people are were talking
about the story did you see this one M
but a lot of people didn't mention that
it was actually the dude who died who
swung
First the full video shows him swinging
first it doesn't mean he was in the
wrong it doesn't mean he wasn't acting
in selfdefense I don't know the full
details of the story but a lot of people
were like he got jumped by 15 people and
and I'm like okay well I watch the video
and there's like five people stomping on
them two of which were not black and I
think there were like three maybe four
that were black and if you watch the
full video it's actually the kid who
died who swings he lunges at a guy and
swings at him and then they rush in and
start beating him so I don't know
exactly what happened or you know it is
what it is it's another reason to be
afraid to send to your kids at school
right well come on where else are they
going to get this type of socialization
just at Congress I guess I guess I'm
open to charging these kids with as
adults at this point I'm like you know
16 years old you know exactly what
you're doing 100% or you don't and
either way it's a problem and you belong
Behind Bars I'm not you but the kid
would hypoth yeah I mean don't stop
Don't Stop on somebody who's on the
ground yeah geez I'm curious though like
just I I I don't know enough about the
case to sit here and be like let's
charge them as adults with murder a lot
of people are screaming to do so and I'm
just like bro I watched a grainy video
of people stomping guy I don't know
anything about it if a dude if you saw
like here's the problem I have there
could be a video of Five Guys stomping
on a dude and they're like oh no why are
they doing that and then someone
releases a video that's got 10 seconds
more and the dude being stomped on is
waving a knife around and screaming and
then throws the knife and starts
punching somebody and like oh okay that
guy's clearly crazy then someone posts
another video of 10 seconds before and
this gang is actively opening fire on a
crowd of people and this guy runs up and
starts waving the knife around saying
stop stop and it's like you just don't
know what happened theoretically that's
why we have trials right so both sides
can present evidence instead we have you
know the media and 24hour news Cycles
it's like we must know exactly right now
now based on very little information
with Kyle writtenhouse we had I think
like five people who were there on this
show telling us here's what we saw and
so we were like okay wow with the video
we've seen and your testimony and Richie
mcginness literally standing there
behind him and helping the dude who get
shot to to the hospital I'm like pretty
sure Kyle ritten housee is acting in
self-defense in this instance all I saw
was a video of some guy stomping at a
guy and him swinging at somebody and I'm
like I don't know are you open to
charging kids as adults now it just
depends on the circumstances but sure
yeah it just it just depends right see
the problem the reason why we have to so
the answer is yes is because gangs will
go to a 13-year-old kid and be like hey
go do you know take this gun and go kill
that guy because you you won't go you'll
get out when you're 18 and then you're
in the gang for life okay so don't do
that no be like nah you you're 13 you
committed a murder we're locking you up
sorry that's like the idea is that the
kids don't know better and you want to
give them a
chance we can't and maybe maybe the
issue is
if we need to go after the dude who gave
the kid the weapon and ordered it and
give that person life or something I
don't think solves the problem anyway to
be honest like the there was that first
Creator in Virginia who brought down to
school and and tried to teach her in the
hand and should her she survived but
he's never been charged because he's too
young he's six they don't think that he
could he would understand but someone
who's 17 and stomping on a classmate's
different yeah there's a big difference
this is a this an important one Hans
grber says WTF the world is coming to uh
the world is coming to an end when Ian
is against freeing the code well I'm
telling you Ian started working out and
everything's changing I'm an
incrementalist I would love to free the
software code but I'm also a realist one
step at a time we go for Tik Tok bite
dance Gandalf the Bas says fist fight
reminds me of the caning of Charles
Sumer in 1856 happened just before the
Civil War due to the tensions leading to
the war say it to him you know you want
to I don't think that Kevin McCarthy
elbowing guy in the back is comparable
to a dude being mercilessly beaten on
the senate floor so you know but we're a
lower testosterone Society now so maybe
we have to maybe we're working up to it
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like inflation
you have to account for it some exactly
Amanda says Ben Franklin actually wanted
Britain and America to stay together
until Parliament humiliated him when he
represented Massachusetts after the
Boston Tea Party then he was all on
board for separation I think that he was
playing them personally I think that his
intention was Revolution the entire time
but you might be
right what have we here Jesus Chris
Jesus crisp trisp to be fair roofs are
like giant wheelchair ramps my paric
buddy just laughed at those
Santas but does he feel represented does
he feel like now he can be Santa yeah uh
I like Tim's idea that he got into like
some sort of cool skateboarding AC just
taking a year off you know everyone
needs to a chance to recover if it's
just go to meico get the stem cells sure
anything PRP storm blood 20 says waiting
on a parody of Santa versus Putin where
Russians go too far north and run into
Santa's North Pole I mean that's
basically like violent nights did you
guys see that one no actually it's a
really good movie sounds awesome yeah
it's Santa is delivering presents at the
same time a group is trying to rob this
wealthy family oh I have seen this movie
yeah and he uses his bag to like fight
it's actually really fun is he if they
got a good martial artist to play Santa
that would be so no it was uh what's his
face the guy from stranger things the
like Sheriff guy yeah oh whatever his
name is and he's married to Lily Allen
yes
guy David Harbor David Harbor that's
right violent eyes was was hilarious it
was good John le was in it that guy's
kind of insufferable but you know he
does a good job in the film so credit
where it's to Beverly D'Angelo she's
great I I recommend violent Knights it's
funny yeah it's like I guess they're
claiming that St Nick was this brutish
nordish Nordic Barbarian who was
mercilessly raping and pillaging until
he became Santa every culture has their
own Santa and doesn't that make you
proud of yours if that's your culture
you know I forget what kids movie it was
but it was like some kids movie where
all the like Tooth Fairy Easter Bunny
were all like real and their version of
Santa was just like this hardcore
Russian like Russian Santa I liked
Russian Santa Russian Santa this is the
thing we have to have Santa that
represents your culture
value what have we here Jeremy wein says
Santa got mugged by Captain
Marvel yeah I mean that's kind of her
Arc she mugged a dude that was the in
the first
movie I okay I'm I'm like this is it
everybody knows but I just got to say it
Captain America was a dude who was weak
and sickly and desperately wanted to get
into the military to serve his country
and Captain Marvel was a woman who had
the power the whole time but a man was
holding her down yeah for real and then
he the Jude log keeps telling her to
control her emotions I'm like oh my God
this is a little too on the nose well
for most female superheroes that that is
what it is or female characters in
general it's not like they need to grow
what their growth is is realizing that
they were great the whole time exactly
they lack the self-esteem to recognize
it that's a line from Gilmore Girls I
just watched this movie I don't know if
anyone knows what it's called where two
women go on vacation to Australia into
this rural town and they get a job at a
pub and I thought it was a horror movie
it's it's a horror movie in the sense
that these women are the villains the
whole time basically what happens is
it's a Rowdy Pub then like one of the
girls is drinking and wants to hang out
with this guy who's not really that good
of a dude and was causing fights so then
the main character gets an Axe and
slashes his tires and then it ends with
them just burning down this Pub and I'm
like what what is this movie like who is
this movie made for I don't understand
but there's a scene where the two women
are like crying with each other about
the bar being Rowdy or something and I
was like you know you'll never see a
movie where it's guys in this
circumstance they they would not make a
movie where it's guys scared and angry
at a bar the guys would always be
aggressive and confrontational kind like
office space is the closest thing to it
I was going to say what about K ugly
that's like a super Rowdy bar that a
bunch of women deal with we already made
this
movie I but this is a very different
movie but that's what I mean like it's
supposed to be like a horror like
there's a point where the guys break
into the bar and I'm like oh wow but
then it's just some guys were trying to
like invite the wom to the Sunset and
I'm like okay what's going on so the
women are the bad bad guys the whole
time I it's supposed to be the good guys
but if you watch it like any rational
person is like yo these women are nuts
they're like anti-heroes no they're not
anti-heroes I was like I really thought
it was going to turn out the women was
going to take an Axe and just go murder
everybody and that was that was like oh
that'd be really cool like it turns out
the character you thought was the scared
victim turns out to be the killer no the
movie just ends they burn the bar down
and leave and it's like why what oh
sounds awful it's just a really bad
movie I think they need to remake
Captain Marvel as the guy who originally
he was Walter Lawson I didn't never read
Marvell Comics but his marll was his
alien name and he came in on Earth he
was known as Walter Larson this whole or
Walter Lawson this whole retconning and
giving it to a woman all for no reason
before they even had an opportunity to
portray him as he was was written makes
no sense I think it's part of the hatred
of that that
franchise so bring back marll funny
because like in in the first movie
Captain Marvel is not a sympathetic
character at all she like mugs the eye
but in the second also she's like called
the annihilator like the Creed blame her
for the yeah yeah I did a hate review of
it it's it's bad but she like she's the
the C I mean spoilers they they call her
the annihilator uh because she basically
destroys their entire society and Planet
by killing their AI leader and it's like
do you want us to like Captain Marvel
because how you are writing her she is
not very likable I you know what I think
it is woke leftists are evil and they're
writing what they think is their power
fantasy so for the average person
Captain America is like a male power
fantasy of I'm going to jump on the
grenade that's going to be me if I was
ever tested I would prove that I'm not a
coward and what these people are doing
is their perspective of the strong
female power fantasy is he told me to
smile I'm going to beat and Rob him it's
like ah well you're the villain so about
that just seems like such an
overreaction like tells you to smile and
so you beat him up calm down team yeah
need to be punished for sexism we'll get
we'll get one more Super here B says
Bernie is Right Senators don't fight
instead they send your sons and
daughters to fight in Foreign Wars that
enrich themselves solution uh O'Brien
and Mullins should nominate some random
family's children to fight in their stad
as per the traditions of Congress or to
be will send their own children to fight
Bernie should have been stop it take it
take it to Israel no it would fight
outside you're a United States Senator
get someone else's kids to fight for you
all right everybody if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends head over to
timcast.net at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast Lauren
do you want to shout anything out yeah
sure so you can follow me basically
everywhere at the Lauren Chen and again
uh blazetv.com with the code Lauren plus
if you Lauren plus if you want to check
out our documentary what really happened
to Maui uh we were on the ground
investigating looking at all of the
incompetence that basically led up to
that tragedy as well as the aftermath
because I mean it's still it's still
going on like the the story hasn't ended
it's just the media has stopped caring
about it so yeah again v.com with the
code Lauren plus as also soaps etsy.com
shop clearly pure c a r l y p r if you
want some uh Christmas presents for the
fam yeah I'm so excited to see your
documentary that's a good project
because you have to get beyond that huge
fench they erected uh I'm Hannah CL RM
I'm a writer for
timcast.net
B and I'm on X at HC brimo thank you
guys so much yes thank you thank you
Lauren for bringing me the soap I will
vouch for its excellence and the
peppermint coffee actually has a coffee
bean in it it does it has real coffee in
the dude I'm going to rub it on my face
the Mountain Fresh so check out get it
some for yourself at etsy.com shop
clearly pure and that's CLE R I'm sorry
CLE e a r you know how to spell clearly
pure it's p r yeah that's the part that
CLE pure on Etsy uh thanks for coming
yeah thank you so much for having me
always a blast hi Serge and I am
surge.com uh I will be in the comments
today to argue with you guys CU some
people want to argue about my hair being
too long which is super weird just like
you know live your own life but whatever
uh let's get to the after talking about
hair as an African-American man we'll
see you all over at timcast.net